foreign
welcome to day six of data science week
by simply learn
on day 5 we understood about machine
learning for data science today we are
going to learn another very crucial data
science skill that is deep learning for
data science
deep learning is a part of machine
learning that uses vast volumes of
structured and unstructured data to
train models data scientists should know
how to train artificial neural network
models such as CNN RNN gen lstm using
libraries such as tensorflow and Keras
we are going to learn all these topics
today so let's dive in and understand
deep learning for data science let's get
started so what is deep learning again
this video is not about deep learning
but there are other videos we have
created in detail about what is deep
learning in this video we'll just touch
upon the basics so that that's like a
nice segue into tensorflow so deep
learning is
um in a way a subset of machine learning
and we use uh primarily neural networks
in deep learning and the underlying
technology behind artificial
intelligence is deep learning and here
we teach them how to recognize let's say
images or voice and so on and so forth
so it is a learning mechanism but here
unlike traditional machine learning the
data is far more complicated and far
more unstructured like it could be
primarily in the form of images or audio
files or text files and one of the core
components of deep learning is neural
network and the neural network somehow
looks like this there is something known
as an input layer and then there is an
output layer and in between there are a
bunch of hidden layers so typically
there would be at least one hidden layer
and anything more than one hidden layer
is known as the Deep neural network so
any neural network with more than three
layers all together right is known as a
deep neural network all right so what
are the functions of the various layers
let's take a quick look so the input
layer accepts the input so this could be
in the form of let's say if it is an
image it could be the pixel values of
the images so that's what the input
layer does and then it passes on to the
hidden layers and the hidden layers in
turn perform certain computations and
they have what is known as as a part of
the training they have these weights and
biases that they keep updating till the
training process is complete and each
neuron has multiple weights and there
will be one bias and these are like
variables and we will see when we go
into the tensorflow code what we
actually mean by that and so that's what
the Heat layer does it does a bunch of
computation and passes its values to the
output layer and then the output layer
in turn gives the output it could be in
the form of a class so for example if we
are doing classification it tells us
which class a particular image maybe
belongs to for example let's say if this
is a image classification application
then the input could be a bunch of
images of maybe cats and dogs and the
output will be like it will say okay if
this is activated this gives a 0 and
this gives a 1 that means it is a cat if
this gives a 1 and this gives a zero
that means it is a dock so that is a
kind of a binary classification and that
can be extended with multiple neurons on
the output side to have many more
classes for example or it can also be
used for regression as well not
necessarily only classification again
since this video is not about deep
learning or machine learning or neural
network we will probably not go into a
lot of details but you can check other
videos where we have give in a lot more
details about neural networks and deep
learning and so on so in order to
develop a deep learning application how
do you go about primarily there are two
or three components that are required in
order to develop deep learning
application you need obviously a
programming language so typically python
is used and that's what we are going to
use in this particular video but you can
also use other languages like Java or C
plus and so on and there are some
libraries that are readily available and
for primarily for doing machine learning
and deep learning programming so these
are a list of libraries these are by no
means the exhaustive list but some of
the most common ones like Keras thiano
tensorflow and so on and so forth
tensorflow has nowadays become very very
popular this is developed by Google and
it is an open source library and keros
was there before now Keras has actually
now become a part of tensorflow as well
so it is one layer about tensorflow so
in that sense they're well integrated
It's a combination of Krrish and
tensorflow is pretty good then of course
you have a torch and tl4j and so on and
so forth so there are multiple libraries
but this video is about tensorflow and
we will be focusing on tensorflow what
are the benefits of tensorflow and what
are its components and our towards the
end we will show you a code in Python
we've written a code in Python by the
way tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers apis now we can earlier without
when these libraries none of these
libraries were there even then we were
doing people were doing machine learning
and deep learning and so on but the
coding mechanism was much more
complicated what these Library select
tensorflow offer is they provide kind of
a high level API so that we don't have
to go really deep into writing all the
stuff that is required wired let's say
to prepare a neural network and to even
configure or even to program a neuron
and so on right so these are done by the
library so all you need to do is they
offer a higher level API you need to use
that API and call that API and maybe
pass the data and that would pretty much
it's much easier rather than actually
going down and writing everything by
yourself so tensorflow that way it
offers apis for to write your code in
python or even C plus plus and and so on
other languages Java as well it has an
integration with r as well apparently
okay and it supports CPUs as well as
gpos now deep learning applications are
very compute intensive especially the
training process needs a lot of
computation it takes very long as you
can imagine because the the data size is
large and there are so many iterative
processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal CPU typically it it would
take much longer but gpus are graphical
processing units you must have heard
gpus in the context of games and so on
because where you need the screen needs
to be of high resolution and the images
need to be of high resolution and so on
so gpus there as the name suggests
graphical Processing Unit were
originally designed for that but since
they are very good at handling this kind
of iterative calculations and so on now
they are kind of they are being used or
leveraged rather for doing or developing
deep learning applications and
tensorflow supports gpus as well as CPUs
so I think that's one of the major
advantages of tensorflow as well now
again what is exactly tensorflow it's a
open source Library developed by Google
and open source and primarily for deep
learning development but tensorflow also
supports traditional machine learning by
the way so if you want to do some
traditional machine learning we can do
it however it is probably a bit of an
overhead to use tensorflow for doing
iteration and machine learning and this
is really good for are performing deep
learning activities and again if you
want to get into more details about
what's the difference between machine
learning and deep learning there is
another video about it you can probably
take a look at that video what else it
is developed originally for large
numerical computations so original even
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as a keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really very good for deep
learning development and therefore
Google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
tensorflow we will see a little bit more
detail the two major components that is
basically the tensors and the graphs
let's take a look at what they are so
what are tensors tensor is as I
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional array in which the
data is stored now when we are doing
deep learning especially the training
process you will have large amounts of
data and the data is in typically in a
very complicated format and it really
helps when you're able to put this use
this or store it in a compact way and so
tensors actually offer a very nice and
compact way of storing the data handling
the data during computation this is not
really for storing all your hard disk or
things like that but in memory when you
are doing the computation tenses are
really really very handy in terms of
keeping the data compact because they
are like multi-dimensional arrays so the
data is stored in tensors and then it is
fed into the neural network and then you
get the output all right so there are
some terms associated with tensors let's
get ourselves familiarized one is the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically Dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi Dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
ranks ranks are basically traditionally
we would have thought of as Dimensions
that is actually in this case it is
called rank so it becomes easier when we
see examples so a tensors rank is
supposed to be zero when there is only
one element we also call this as scalar
so just one element and this is not
really a vector it's just an element
like 200 it's also known as a scalar so
such a tensor is supposed to be having a
rank of zero then you have let's say one
dimensional array this is a vector with
a row of L elements this has rank of one
now if you have traditionally what we
called as a two-dimensional like a
matrix for example then the rank is 2
and in this case the rank is three and
it can have more ranks as well as I
mentioned it is like a multi-dimensional
array so you can have rank five six and
so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
I know this is a slightly New Concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first cut but when we look at the code
when we go into the tutorial The Code
walkthrough I think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph now
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we'll
also see that whenever you start a
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as the default graph and then
different required I know probably in
the beginning it may not be required but
in more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely Illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular CPUs or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as I
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or CPUs and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for repairing a graph
and then you create what is known as a
session and then in that session you ask
the session to execute this graph so
this will again become much clearer when
we look at the code before we can see
the differences between these platforms
we first need to know what exactly each
of these platforms are let's start with
tensorflow what is tensorflow tensorflow
is a low level software Library which is
created by Google to help Implement
machine learning models and to solve
complex numerical problems tensorflow is
nothing but a free and open source
software library for machine learning it
can be used across the range of tasks
but has a particular focus on training
and inference of deep neural networks
tensorflow is a symbolic math Library
Based on data flow and differential
programming it is used for both research
and production at Google what do you
mean by data flow it basically means
that we perform calculations by
converting every element into graphical
form the variables of the graph are
called tensors and mathematical
operations are called operators here in
the computational graph shown you can
see that x y and 2 are the variables
they will also be called tensors and
division multiplication and addition are
the operators
this graph basically shows us the
calculation that is going to occur in a
machine learning model
where X and Y are going to be divided
and Y and 2 are going to be multiplied
the results of these two calculations
are then going to be added to give us
the final output I told you that x y and
2 are also called tensors what exactly
are tensors tensors are
multi-dimensional arrays with a uniform
type all tensors are immutable like
python numbers and strings which means
that you cannot update the contents of a
tensor you can only create a new tensor
next let's look at the API Keras
what exactly is Keras Keras is a higher
level deep learning API written in
Python for easy implementation and
computation of neural networks Keras is
an open source software library that
provides a tensorflow interface for
artificial neural networks Keras acts as
an interface for the tensorflow library
which means that it runs on top of
tensorflow up until version 2.3 Keras
supported multiple back-ends
including tensorflow Microsoft cognitive
toolkit
or cntk R Tiano and played ml as a
version 2.4 only tensorflow is supported
as of version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported designed to help enable fast
experimentation with deep neural
networks in it focuses on being
user-friendly modular and extensible
Keras is a high level API of tensorflow
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with the focus on Modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing and shipping machine learning
Solutions with high iteration velocity
Keras does not perform its own low level
operations such as tensor products and
convolution it relies on back-end
engines for that even though Keras
supports multiple back-end engines its
primary back-end engine is tensorflow
and its primary supporter is Google
which means that Keras acts as nothing
more but a wrapper class around
tensorflow thiano cntk played ml or
mxnet which are low level apis next we
will look at pytorch what exactly is pi
touch pytorch is a low level API which
is developed by Facebook for national
language processing and computer vision
it is a more powerful version of numpy
it is an open source machine learning
library based on the torch Library used
for applications such as computer vision
and natural language processing
primarily developed by Facebook's AI
research lab it is free and open source
software released under the modified BSD
license although the python interface is
a more polished and the primary focus of
development pytorch also has a c plus
interface python is a widely liked
language because it is easy to
understand and write pytorch emphasizes
flexibility and allows deep learning
models to be expressed in basic python
pytouch is mainly used for national
language processing
and for computer vision now let's move
on to the differences between tensorflow
Keras and pytorch
the first difference that we'll be
looking at is called level of API there
are two main types of apis a low level
API and a high level API apis stands for
application programming interface
a low-level application programming
interface is generally more detailed and
allows you to have more detailed control
to manipulate functions within them on
how to use and Implement them while a
high level API is more generic and
simple and provides more functionality
with one command statements than a lower
level API high level interfaces are
comparatively easier to learn and to
implement the models using them they
allow you to write code in a shorter
amount of time and to be less involved
with the details in this case tensorflow
is a high and low level API pure
tensorflow is a low level API while
tensorflow wrapped in Keras is a high
level API
Keras in itself is a high level API
which uses multiple low-level apis as a
backend and simplifies the operation of
these low-level apis
pytorch is a low level API
the next criteria that we'll be looking
at is speed tensorflow is very fast and
is used for high performances Keras is
slower as it works on top of tensorflow
not only does it have to wait for
tensorflow to finish implementation it
then starts its own implementation
meanwhile pytorch works at the same
speed as tensorflow as both of them are
both low level apis now Keras is a
wrapper class for tensorflow and has
added abstraction functionalities on top
of tensorflow which make it slower than
tensorflow and Pie torch in computation
speed both tensorflow and Pi torch are
almost equal and in development speed
Keras is faster as it has built-in
functionalities which can significantly
reduce your development time the next
difference is on the architecture
tensorflow is not very easy to use and
even though it provides Keras as a
framework that makes it work easier
tensorflow still has a very complex
architecture which is hard to use
meanwhile Keras is a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in Keras significantly easier pie touch
on the other hand also has a complex
architecture and the readability is less
when compared to Keras tensorflow uses
computational graphs which makes it very
complex and hard to interpret but it has
amazing computational ability across
platforms pytorch is a little hard for
beginners but is really good for
computer vision and deep learning
purposes data sets and debugging
tensorflow works with large data sets
due to its high execution speed and
debugging is really hard in tensorflow
due to its complex nature meanwhile
Keras only works with very small data
sets as its speed of execution is low
programs do not require frequent
debugging in Keras as they are
relatively simpler and pytorch can
manage high level tasks in higher
Dimension data sets and is easier to
debug than both Keras and tensorflow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development as we said before tensorflow
works with many hard Concepts such as
computational graphs and tensors which
means that writing code in tensorflow is
very hard it is generally used by people
when they are doing research work and
really need very specific
functionalities
Keras on the other hand provides a high
level of abstraction which makes it very
easy to use it is best for people who
are just starting out with python and
machine learning pie torch is easier
than tensorflow but is still
comparatively hard than Keras it is not
very easy to learn for beginners but is
significantly more powerful than just
plain carers ease of deployment
tensorflow is very easy to deploy as it
uses tensorflow serving tensorflow
serving is a flexible high performance
serving system for machine learning
models designed for production
environments tensorflow serving makes it
easy to deploy new algorithms and
experiments while keeping the same
server architecture and apis tensorflow
serving provides out of the box
integration with tensorflow models but
can be easily extended to serve other
types of models and data in Keras model
deployment can be done with either
tensorflow serving or flask which makes
it relatively easy but not as easy as
you as it would be with tensorflow and
Pie torch pie touch uses iTouch mobile
which makes deployment easy but again
for tensorflow deployment is way easier
as tensorflow serving can update your
machine learning backend on the fly
without the user even realizing there's
a growing need to execute ml models on
edge devices to reduce latency preserve
privacy and enable new interactive use
cases in the past Engineers used to
train models separately they would then
go through a multi-step error-prone and
often complex process to train the
models for execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience
all of these frictions have been removed
by pi torch Mobile by allowing a
seamless process to go from training to
deployment by staying entirely within
the pytorch ecosystem it provides an
end-to-end workflow that simplifies the
research to production environment for
mobile devices in addition it paves the
way for privacy preserving features via
Federated learning techniques
at the end of the day the question that
really matters is which framework should
you use Keras tensorflow or Pi torch
now tensorflow has implemented various
levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier Keras is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensorflow it is
more user friendly than any other deep
learning API however and is easier to
learn for beginners by torch on the
other hand is the preferred deep
learning API for teachers but it is not
as widely used in production as
tensorflow is it is faster but it has
lower GPU utilization
at the end of the day the framework that
we would suggest that you use is
tensorflow
why while Pi torch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tensorflow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production pie
torches ease of use combined with the
default ego execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky Solutions and smaller scale
models but tensorflow's extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
overhead makes it the preferred option
for companies that work with deep
learning models in addition the
tensorflow board visualization features
offers a nice way of showing the inner
workings of your model to say your
customers
meanwhile between tensorflow and Keras
the main difference isn't in performance
tensorflow is a bit faster due to less
overhead but also the level of control
you would like Keras is much easier to
start with than plain tensorflow but if
you want to do something with Keras that
doesn't come out of the box it will be
harder to implement that tensorflow on
the other hand allows you to create any
arbitrary computational graph providing
much more flexibility so if you're doing
more research type of work tensorflow is
the sure route to go due to the
flexibility that it provides welcome to
the session on installing tensorflow my
name is Mohan and I am going to take you
through the process of setting up this
tensorflow development environment as
some of you may be aware it's not that
easy to set up the tensorflow
environment there are several components
there are several possibilities for
example you can set up on Windows you
can sit upon Ubuntu now Ubuntu has
multiple versions which version to use
and then you have python which release
of python to use whether to do a pip
install whether to do install using
anaconda and how do you then link it up
with jupyter notebook these are multiple
possibilities and it takes up a lot of
time to try all of these so today what
I'm going to do is show you a tried and
tested method of setting up the
tensorflow environment and this will
help primarily those who are starting
with tensorflow so that they don't have
to waste so much time on setting up the
environment in experimenting with the
insulation and setting up of the
environment now what we are going to do
is I will show you a method by which you
you know it is a tight and tested method
and of course tensorflow home page has a
install page and it shows you some ways
to install but again the challenge is
the same there are multiple versions
multi method shown there so it's highly
confusing for somebody who is new as to
decide which one which path to take so
in today's session what we are going to
do is we will set up tensorflow on
Ubuntu and I'm going to show you in a
virtual box but then if you are using a
laptop with Ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of Ubuntu and
Python and then tensorflow not all of
them are compatible with each other so
these versions and releases need to be
very specific so I will tell you which
is the version and releases or what
combination is best suited for you to
get started and later on of course you
can then experiment with other
possibilities and other releases and so
on once you get familiar with tensorflow
to start with I would also like to
mention that it is a good idea to
install or start with Ubuntu environment
or a Linux any other Linux also but here
we will focus on Ubuntu rather than
Windows so for those who are already
let's say using a Windows system the
question may arise what do we do but
there is an easy option as you can see I
am actually using a virtual box so you
need to install virtualbox let me just
show you so this is the virtualbox
Oracle VM virtual box and there are tons
of videos on YouTube how to install a
virtualbox and how to create a Ubuntu
image I think we will not spend time on
that but if you're using Windows and my
preference would be to set up a virtual
box and set up your environment in
Ubuntu image so we will start by
assuming that you have an Ubuntu
environment especially release 14.04 LTS
there are multiple one two versions and
again we will not try to get the latest
and the greatest versions or latest and
greatest releases but the focus here is
to take the releases and versions which
are working and where you will not waste
time so the setup process will be smooth
if you stick to these releases you can
of course experiment later on with other
versions and try out but here we will be
working with Ubuntu 1404 LTS and we will
use Python 3.4 and we will use
tensorflow 1.5 this is a tried and
tested combination and I would also
recommend that you use the same if you
want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that let me log in to my
Ubuntu system okay so we have the Ubuntu
system running here now if you go to
tensorflow.org there is a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have Ubuntu you have
Windows and Mac OS and so on and so
forth and if you go to Ubuntu for
example further you will get multiple
options whether you want CPU or GPU and
whether you want to do a pip install or
using a virtual native pip virtual Envy
anaconda and so on and so forth so all
these options are very complicated or
rather very confusing I would say not
complicated depending on whether you're
expert or of course I am talking about
beginners here but if you click on some
of these options they may look very easy
so for example if we go back and if you
select for example native pip it may
appear like oh this is just you know one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say bit three install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the Simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
Anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what I am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course I
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as I said I will show you
the steps which are again Sure Shot to
work whereas here again if you follow
just this document there will be some
variations which they have kind of not
documented so that's the reason I will
show you the steps separately all right
so these are the main four steps you
need to download and install anaconda
and then create a virtual environment
with python and release as I mentioned
is Python 3.4 and we will install
tensorflow version 1.5 and then we will
install and configure Jupiter which will
be our development environment all right
so let's get started this is our Ubuntu
and let's get a terminal started here
and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the Anaconda website because we need to
install Anaconda we need to download and
install Anaconda so for that you need to
go to the Anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
Google and you will find website
so this is the site
anaconda.org click on this link and it
will take you to the Anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
Anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
Ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download right so as you can see it has
recognized that you are on a Linux
operating system so you can just click
on this download and down
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 I recommend you start with
python 3.6 now just want to clarify that
we will be actually using Python 3.4
this is just for the initial
installation but subsequently when we
set up the virtual environment you will
see there is one more step where we set
up the virtual environment there we will
actually be using Python 3.4 so just
that you are not confused all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this and it is downloading
while it is downloading you can click on
this link saying how to install Anaconda
so there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's time all right so once the
download is done we will be using the
options that are mentioned here now the
first step of course is we we are
already doing the first step which is
downloading the installer for Linux the
second step is not mandatory so it's an
optional step most often you can
actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and since we are
using at this point we are using python
3.6 we should use this command so
basically the terminal we have opened
here is is to use or to run this command
that's the reason I open this terminal
however make sure that the download is
complete before you run this command so
we'll just wait for a couple of minutes
and we'll come back once the download is
done all right so as you can see the
download is done this is a fairly large
file so if you are on a slow internet or
low internet bandwidth then it might
take quite a while it's about
578 MB and so this is the file now what
you need to do is you need to go back to
this installation steps and let me
minimize this and
so this is the command that you need to
run so you can just directly copy and
paste this command from here
okay so I do copy right Mouse like
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step I will
just show you what I mean and here you
need to do press enter multiple times
just to make sure you agree to all these
agreement uh the license agreement and
so on and so forth so once you do
multiple
enters it will bring you to the next
step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and this is primarily
when it will pretty much start the
installation process of anaconda this
might take a little while depending
again on your internet speed so you need
to have some patience we will also
probably come back once this
installation is done or if I if it asks
for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you use to wish the
installer to pre-pen so you just say yes
for this question and
keep going now the last question
I think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about Microsoft
VSS I guess yeah vs code so for this you
can just say no because we will not be
using this and that's it you're done so
this is a completion of installation of
anaconda so it's always a good idea to
exit and start a fresh terminal okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the installation of
Anaconda the next step is to create a
virtual environment with Python 3.4 so
for that this is the command conda
create dash n and this is the name of
your virtual environment you can give
any name but for easy reference I have
given as tensorflow and we have to
specify the python version as I
mentioned earlier we will be using the
combination of Python 3.4 and tensorflow
1.5 now this is not the latest version
python has probably 3.6 at this point at
the time of creation of this video and
even tensorflow probably has the latest
version as 1.7 but then these
combinations sometimes may not work and
I found that after several trials and
errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to be most
reliable and that's the reason I have
chosen this I would recommend you to try
with this first if you are a beginner
and later on maybe you can try out other
permutations and combinations all right
one step I just wanted to show you is
before we do the installation or
creation of the virtual environment if
you want to just clarify or confirm
whether Anaconda has been installed or
not you can run what is known as
Anaconda Navigator so just say Anaconda
Navigator
okay we need to edit this part hold on
one second I guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
Anaconda Navigator this
Anaconda Navigator will open up that is
a indication that Anaconda has been
installed properly so that's just a
quick check and you don't have to do
anything just you can go back and close
it uh once this comes up and then in the
meanwhile let me just open one more
terminal
for the creation of the virtual
environment and and yeah so this is your
anaconda Navigator and you can just say
okay don't show me let me just say okay
and
um
then you can close this
you can say file you can do a file exit
or you can click on the close button
whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a terminal open here we will use
this for our next steps all right so
what we have to do now is Type in this
piece off
code or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so it's a small command so it
shouldn't be that big of an issue so we
say conda
[Music]
and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash
dash n and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for uh
convenience I'm just calling it
tensorflow but you can actually name it
anything and then we need to specify
with which version of python so we say
pip
Python and then that is equal
3.4 okay so it will create an
environment this will take a little
while it'll ask you a question just say
yes and then it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and for the question that it asks you
just say yes and I think you should be
good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes and then enter
this will again take a little bit a
little time so we will probably move
forward and then come back once this is
done
all right so the environment has been
created now it's always a good idea to
whenever some of these steps get over or
each step gets over you just exit the
terminal and start afresh with the new
terminal for some reason sometimes it
causes problem if you continue so I
found that it is a safe practice too
each time exit the terminal and start
afresh now that we have an environment
created we can by the name tensorflow
you can enter that environment by
calling the command Source activate
tensorflow or the name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
uh from here onwards you can do other
stuff like actually installing
tensorflow and so on and you will see
that it has installed Python 3 here so
3.4 right so it is installed that's what
we during creation of this environment
we wanted Python 3.4 so that is what it
is showing but we are not yet done so we
need to still install tensorflow so in
this environment you need to run a
command which will actually install the
crit combination of tensorflow now this
is as you can see it's a slightly
complicated command with install
dash dash ignore instance so what we can
do is from within here we can go and go
to tensorflow install page and there is
a sample code there you can pick up from
there so that you don't have to type in
so much so we say tensorflow
tensorflow let's explore.org and I'll
also open up probably a notepad here so
that we can construct that command and
go here
is a Ubuntu if you come further down
there will be by the way we are doing
CPU installation I think that is clear
we are not there is a possibility to do
GPU as well we will probably create a
separate video for that and if we go
here yeah so again you probably if you
follow the entire document out here it
may still not work so I do not recommend
that for now at least for beginners but
just to copy this command because this
is a fairly complicated command so this
is much easier to copy it from here
that's the reason I'm on this page
and we will then modify it according to
yes okay let's see
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document I'll just say TF Dot txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the versions that
we are installing here so let me just
explain what it is what you need to do
so first thing you can get rid of this
one yes okay now here these parts you
can simply ignore here you need to go
and change it to version 1.5
and I think we are good with that okay
so the cp34 indicates your Python 3.4 so
later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to do other
combinations of tensorflow and python
version then you can change this for
example you can change this to 3 6 both
these places you need to change this to
3 6 if you are using with python 3.6 and
similarly if you want the latest version
which is of tensorflow which is 1.7 you
need to change this to 1.7 and so on but
at this point to start with if you are a
beginner I would recommend that you
stick to this tensorflow 1.5 with Python
3.4 this is tried and test it and it
works okay just a word of course
question that just by changing these
versions to the whole thing will not
work there may be other places where you
may have to some of the steps may change
so just a word of caution that just by
changing this if you want to try out
with a different version some of the
steps may also change so you don't think
that just by changing this just one
particular command you will be uh fine
okay so that's been my experience so to
start with I would recommend use this
particular combination all right so it
looks good uh tensorflow 1.5 and let me
just reconform with my notes and I think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34 and so on okay
okay so let's hit enter
it started the process again this might
take a little while so we will pause the
recording and then get back when the
installation is done okay so looks like
this installation is done and as always
let us
exit and then come back now you're
currently in the environment virtual
environment and it's a good practice
before you exit out of the terminal to
come out or out of the virtual
environment so just like you did Source
activate you need to do Source
deactivate
and the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can do an exit now we need to
validate whether the tensorflow
installation has gone through properly
or not so the way to validate is to
first start Python and then import
tensorflow Library see if it Imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into the
environment this is how you have to do
come to environment and then say source
and obviously you can also use existing
so Source activate
tensorflow okay so we do this and you
need to run python from here and
remember you should say Python 3 because
you have installed Python 3.4 now here
when you say import
tensorflow
SDF when you get back up prompt like
this without any errors that means
tensorflow installation has been
successful if tensorflow was not
installed properly you will get an error
saying tensorflow is not available our
module doesn't exist or something like
that so tensorflow installation is done
but now we will go through the process
of installing jupyter notebook so that
you can do your development so let me
just exit and in order to install your
jupyter notebook which is your which is
going to be your development environment
we will first install IPython using
conda so conda install IPython and then
pip install Jupiter so let's first do
the I button on the
install
Pi python again it will ask you a
question saying these are the components
do you want to install you just say yes
right you say yes
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
so they did not take much
time anyways so we will as usual we will
exit which is Source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal in order to install Jupiter
now uh in some places uh they may say
um install Jupiter using Victory but in
my experience it did not work with P3
and that's the reason we will use pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so Source
activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is PIP install Jupiter usually when
you're on Python 3 you use bit 3 but as
I said it did not work so
in my experience it works with fit
install
and start with three so pip install
Jupiter
I hope you already noticed that it is
j-u-p-y-d-e-r
and not JPI
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done okay so
Jupiter installation is also done once
again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to come out
of this terminal session and then start
afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here and we will once
again
go to tensorflow
and we say Jupiter
notebook
that's how you start your Jupiter
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running uh for the first
time what you need to do is if you come
back to your command prompt it will show
you that if you're running it for the
first time it will say that you need to
copy paste this link so you you can just
for the first time only once you need to
do this copy this
and paste it in your browser and
remember this is only the first time
when you're running Jupiter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
Jupiter installed and it starts up we
need to test whether tensorflow is
working fine or not and in order to do
that you can create a new
notebook
and you say import
tensorflow as TF shift enter if
everything is fine then Supply is
installed properly you don't get any
errors and then it works fine this is an
indication that tensorflow got installed
successfully and that's about it so
that's all about installing tensorflow
with Python 3.4 so remember this is
installation of tensorflow 1.5 with
Python 3.4 on Ubuntu and uh once again
in case you have a Windows system in
fact I have also done it on a Windows
system you can use Virtual blocks to
create a virtual environment Ubuntu
environment and then follow these steps
and there are tons of videos to create
virtualbox and that's the reason we have
not included those steps in this and if
there are any comments there are better
ways to do this please mention it in the
comment section below or if you need any
further help just mention it and with
your email we will respond to you now
what are the various elements of a
tensorflow program as I mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if familiar with python this may
still be new for you the way you write a
tensorflow program is different from the
regular Python Programming that you
would have done or even machine learning
program you would have written some
machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example B is equal to T F
dot constant and then you give a value
here a slightly more advanced version is
you also specify the type so you say TF
dot constant 2.0 TF load 32 so the type
is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of B from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we are all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables TF dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have V capital
okay constant has C the small C and
placeholder as small P but variable as
capital V and TF dot variable and then
you give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code I will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas the constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders are
really a special type and this may be
something completely new for many of us
who have been doing programming but in
tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a CSV file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle the memory and
so on so I think that was the reason
they came up with this mechanism where
you can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dick feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
Name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you handle
data within a tensorflow program and
then you create a graph and once you
create a graph then you have what is
known as a session and then you create a
session object and you create a session
and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or TF this TF here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much easier to understand so
when you create a tensorflow object
there is like a default graph which
doesn't have any operations no nodes or
anything like that so it's like a clean
slate the moment you assign variables or
constants or placeholders each of them
is in tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you're just creating a
constant or a variable but and this C is
equal to a into B would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they are also known as
referred to as nodes and when you're in
your session you will actually run each
of these you can potentially run each of
these nodes okay so a typical example
would look like this so you have two
constants created a is equal to TF dot
constant its value is 5 b is equal to
this and then you say C is equal to a
into B and then you create a session now
remember all this you're just creating a
graph at this point no execution has
happened all right so only at this point
once you create a session and then you
say session access dot run C is when
actually this whole thing will get
executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing program
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupyter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the lab and
take a look at the various examples that
are there and starting from the very
basic one how you create variables and
so these are some of the slides that are
showing so this is about how to create
variables how to create constants and
the variables or constants can also be
strings so this is like our first hello
world program and we will talk about
placeholders how to define a placeholder
and how to execute and populate the
placeholder values into placeholder we
will see these examples in the lab
actually I will run the code and we will
also perform a small computation of
adding and multiplying these variables
and we will in the end we will take up
our use case implementation using
tensorflow so let's first go and see
those examples and then come back and
I'll explain this use case and then we
will execute the use case in the lab so
let's go and check our lab okay so I'm
in the jupyter notebook environment and
this is one of the development
environments we can use this is regular
python anytime you do Python Programming
we use Jupiter notebook or there are
rather of course there are other ways of
using other tools like charm and so on
but for this particular tutorial I am
comfortable using Jupiter notebook so I
will show you in jupyter Notebook so
this is the very basic example to
demonstrate how to create variables and
constants and placeholders and what is
the difference between them how they
behave and so on and as I mentioned the
Assumption here is that you know at
least some basic Python Programming or
some programming language so at least
you understand the code here and first
two pieces of code you will not need
machine learning background but when we
do the use case or the case study there
it is expected that you know at least
some basic machine learning Concepts so
in case you need to brush up the machine
learning part you may have to do that
before you go to the third one but here
just at least some idea of programming
will be sufficient so what are we doing
here in this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as I mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it TF so this is this
just a name you can give it any name but
it is very common and everywhere
wherever tensorflow programming is done
it is always named as TF but you can
name anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable I'm
starting by giving a name called 0 and I
say 0 is equal to TF dot variable and
then I'm giving the value of the
variable here so this is the very basic
way and the simplest way to create a
variable we will see a little later
there are other formats as well but the
bare minimum way of creating a variable
is this so I'm creating a variable by
the name zero and as I mentioned you
need to pay attention to the capital V
here in case of variable it is a capital
V uppercase constant and placeholders
are lowercase now I'm creating a
constant then the constant I'm naming it
as one and the way to create a constant
is TF dot constant and then you give the
value of the constant so the value of
the variable here is 0 and the value of
constant here is 1 and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on probably you must
have seen in other tutorials or in other
places where the code is written but the
basic format to construct to create a
constant is this this is sufficient to
create a constant so I created one
variable and one constant now what else
can we do again here there is no real
execution happening we are just building
a graph we have not yet executed any
tensorflow code we are building a graph
and I will show you how the graph looks
as well first let us understand the
constants and variables and so on and
then I will show you how the graph is
generated and so on so what I want to do
here is I want to add 0 and 1 and put it
into a new variable called new value so
what I do here tensorflow offers these
methods like add assign multiply or you
have matrix multiplication mat model and
so on right so I will use one of those
methods which is TF dot add and then
pass these two as parameters so we can
add a variable and a constant there are
no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if I
do this it will be okay I did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
TF dot add 0 1. so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
I want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has 1
because we added a 0 and a one so new
value has one now I want to assign this
to this originally what we called as 0.
so I will call that as update is equal
to TF dot assign so assign is basically
changing the value so that's what we are
going to do here now it has not complete
plane we'll just say fine right there
are no issues now let us try this
something similar with this one as well
so 0 is a variable so we were able to
change the value and we will in a little
while we will see what exactly those
values are but before doing that now
let's say I will uncomment this part and
I want to do something similar for my
constant right one is a constant now I
want to let's say change the value of
the constant and make that also
something different okay so if I execute
this piece of code it will give an error
now again the error message may not be
very intuitive this doesn't say that you
cannot do this for a constant it will
just say tensor object has no attribute
assigned now that sometimes may be
confusing especially when you are
starting but the meaning here is that
one is a constant and you're trying to
modify the constant so it will not allow
that's the reason it is complaining so
let's put that back in the comment and
okay so that is done so on only
variables you can modify now what you
have to do let's skip this piece of code
I'll come back to this in a bit but
let's say we start by creating you
remember I told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called SAS or you can
give any name and that is equal to TF
dot session that is the session method
here and you create a session object by
the name SAS now what I'll do is I'll
skip this as well I there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember I mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you run through
the session is when the actually the
program gets executed so when you do
this now you see observe of that it is
giving an error Okay the reason behind
that is remember we skip these two lines
of code for variables okay this and then
this now this is something very very
important to observe if you have
variables in your code what I mean by
that is let's say you are not using
variables but you have only constants
and placeholders then this will not
complain and you will not get this error
but in our case we also have variables
so whenever you have variables in that
case you need to do an initialization
and this is just a standard code there
is nothing that we need to add or modify
or anything like that this is a standard
piece of code you create this name of
course can be anything you can give us
any name but this Global variables
initializer is what you need to call TF
dot Global variables initializer this
will kind of initialize all the
variables that you may be using and then
again remember this doesn't execute
anything right so all you're doing here
is you're creating an operation but in
order to run that operation you need to
also run this known as run init
underscore op so this operation you need
to run after creating the session all
right so we executed this now let us
execute this and now when I run this
piece of code it will run successfully
okay I hope you observed that so it is
whenever you use variables these two
lines of code one is the operation you
need to create an operation for saying
Global variables initializer and then
you need to run before running anything
else you need to do a session dot run
this operation okay again only if you
are using variables of course you
invariably in all your programs you will
use variables you cannot just write a
program with constants and placeholders
so you can pretty much assume that this
has to be there in pretty much all the
programs now again why this has not been
taken care of in the live Library that's
a different question but you need to
keep in mind and always remember if you
don't do this for whatever reason if you
have forgotten you will get an error and
the error won't be intuitive so you need
to remember this that this could be
because of the variables okay good so we
have seen how to create a constant and
we have seen how to create a variable
and we have seen that you cannot modify
or update a constant and we have also
seen if you have variables that you need
to execute or have these two lines of
code to initialize the variables and
then we have seen that after creating a
graph how to run the graph in a session
and I will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and we will also show
you or I will show you the placeholders
but before that one more small piece of
code so this this is how you write a for
Loop okay so we are saying five times
you run this piece of code now like any
Python program this is nothing different
so you have a for Loop and this is
indented that's the reason and therefore
you say session dot Run update so this
will run five times and it will get
printed that's all so update will run
for five times each time it will come
and do this particular operation that's
all we are we are asking the system to
do so let me just run that and show you
let me yeah so it will okay so it has
done five times
one that's for it is basically adding if
you recall it starts from zero it adds
one to zero then one to one one to two
and so on so it's nothing but it is
generating five numbers one two three
four five that's it okay so then you you
can also have your constants as strings
for example so you can also work in a
similar way you can work with string so
most of the computation happens mainly
on numerical values so we normally had
handle numbers but there will be
situations where you may have to handle
strings as well or text as well so this
is an example of text operation so you
can similar to numbers you just create
strings or store in constants instead of
a number you say hello is equal to TF
dot constant and then you assign the
string that you want it to be assigned
and then the next one is one more string
which is for world and then you say add
these two so it is nothing but
concatenation of these two words hello
and word so we will do that and remember
this is only creation of the graph right
so in order to actually execute this
graph you need to run the session now
you need to keep in mind we don't have
to create the session once again again
because once you create a session till
you close the session it remains valid
okay so we have created this session
here now till you say SAS Dot close it
will remain for you so that's why we did
not create one more so we are just
reusing that session says dot run hello
world so in this hello world what is the
operation that we are doing here the
operation is add these two concatenate
these two so if I run this it will print
hello world okay now that's string
operation now we will take a look at
placeholders so this is a slightly more
complicated and something new even for
people who have been writing programs so
but I'll just explain it with uh with a
quick example first of all how do you
declare or create a placeholder you just
do TF dot placeholder and the p is
lowercase only in case of variables the
B is uppercase but otherwise constantly
sold as it is lowercase and you just say
because as I mentioned this is a
placeholder it doesn't have any value so
you unlike a constant or your variable
you can't usually you will not specify
any value you just say what type of
placeholder you want and very often most
of the cases it is a floating point so
we just say placeholder of type float32
so this TF dot floor 32 tells the system
that it is a floating Point okay okay
and then so let me just run this and
then you can do some or Define some
computation like for example B is equal
to a into two now remember here right
now A has no value but what we are
saying here is at any point later on
when a gets some value then B should be
equal to twice the value of a that's all
we are saying here okay and also as I
mentioned earlier we are not yet
executing anything we are just creating
a graph here okay so now you have that
now how do you feed the value or
populate the placeholder there is a
certain syntax in which you can populate
the placeholder and you do that using
what is known as a dictionary you're all
probably familiar those with python
specially must be familiar with the
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that in order
to feed the placeholder so in this
particular example if I want to run
something if I want to calculate or
compute B obviously I need to feed the
value of a so the value of a I'm feeding
using this dictionary and I'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or a tensor very often
it is a tensor so we will see step by
step so we can start with a very basic
example where a can be a scalar so in
this case a is equal to 3 that's what we
are saying feed underscore date in this
case feed underscore dick is the name of
a variable by the way so you can't give
anything else here so if you just say
feed is equal to this it will give you
an error all right so keep that in mind
either you specify feed underscore dick
is equal to and give the dictionary pass
the dictionary or you'll straight away
like in this case this is another format
so let's see first let me execute this
it has given 6 okay I think let me see
if I can clear out this particular cell
so it becomes easier to understand okay
so it is giving you six let me do that
once again clear out this and then okay
and let me change the format so this is
one way of doing it another way is you
don't even have to specify the name of
this parameter feed underscore deck you
just pass the dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so I will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so I hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
B and what exactly is BB is twice a a
into two so therefore what we're doing
and a has not been doesn't have any
value out here right so that's why we
are feeding the value of a and then the
operation gets come completed so a gets
a value of 3 and then it gets multiplied
by 2 because that's what we said here
therefore b gets a value of 6 and that's
what is being fed into a result and
that's what is getting printed here okay
now as I mentioned a need not be just a
scalar value it can be a vector with a
multi-dimension array and so on and so
forth so let's start showing you uh
examples of that okay let me just clear
out the outputs let me clear this and
let me also clear this for now okay you
can also do before running up this you
could we could also do clear all output
all output clear it will clear
everything but that will we'll have to
start all over again so I'm just doing
individually all right so in this
example we are taking a one dimension
array where rank is equal to one and I'm
feeding three four five now let us see
what happens if I run this right as you
can imagine it gets multiplied each
number gets multiplied so the result is
6 8 10 okay now as I said it can get
more complicated now let's say this is a
multi-dimensional vector so if you what
happens if you feed this okay so as you
can see this is pretty complicated now
but if you feed this again all you're
doing is uh there is okay there is a
slight change here again you can also
Create Your Dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there's a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it's
more complicated and then you are
passing the dictionary here so I said
dictionary is equal to a and then I'm
saying this is what should be the value
of a this is and I'm feeding that and
then I am using directly that dictionary
here okay so this is equivalent to
putting this code here right so if we
exit give this what happens same so you
get because a was a let's say this is a
3 by 4 by 2 right so that is one yeah
three by four by two right so you see
here this is a multi-dimensional array
so you feed that and the values you see
here it is one two three it became two
four six four five six became eight ten
twelve seven eight nine became 14 16 18
and so on and so forth okay I hope now
you've got an idea about placeholders
and in real life what happens is you
typically won't create these
dictionaries manually and this is a
quick demo we did this you will actually
read the data into this dictionary and
then you feed that when you're doing the
computation okay so it could be a CSV
file or it could be a image file so the
input is basically read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
they can be large amount of data so that
is the idea idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision
there's a deliberately that has been
made a provision for this kind of
getting data into the program in chunks
okay now in this particular example we
will close the session here and then I
will show you what is other way of
creating a session right so now if I
close the session here now if I try to
do anything with the session it will
give us an error so I will probably not
do that right now now there is another
way or another format and this is a very
common way of using the session but I
didn't want to start off with this
because this could get a little
confusing the a simpler way was to
create session saying s is equal to TF
dot session but typically you will do it
in what is known as a width block this
is a very common way of creating session
so once you have the graph you would
execute the graph in a session using a
width block and this is the syntax so
you say with TF dot session as says all
right and then you put all your code
here so what will happen is you don't
have to explicitly close the session the
moment this with block gets completed
the session gets closed okay so let's
just take a quick look at this example
now if I uh let me clear this current
output be clear okay so this is the
hello world example a little bit earlier
we did that so I'm doing with TF dot
session assassin result is equal to SAS
dot run hello Plus World and then I say
print result okay so within this with
block I'm doing all my computation and
this gets executed now let's say I try
to run remember I created a session here
now if I want to let's say do something
like run search dot run a it is giving
an error because the session is no
longer valid right so you cannot either
you have to run this if you want to run
this you have to run this in this with
block or you shouldn't have closed the
session here right you remember this we
said session Dot close so since we have
closed the session there is no active
session therefore it is giving an error
okay now there is a third way of
creating a session but for now I will
skip it because that is very very
specific to the notebooks and and so on
so we will just avoid it you start with
for beginners I think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
Dot close it will not give any error or
anything like that only thing is that
it's a good practice and your resources
will get released otherwise if you do
multiple of these programs if they are
running then your resources will get
blocked that's the only thing and to
start with it is it is simpler to do it
this way so initially in you're doing
you start with this but as you move
forward as you become familiar with the
tensorflow programming I would recommend
all of you to get into this model most
of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with
df.session SS okay all right so that was
one book or one page of code that we
have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders now let me
explain how the graph works so in this
example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on okay now that we got
a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as I said whenever you
create a TF or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see we have not done
anything we have not created a constant
or variable or nothing right so there
was there is no operation so by the way
let's do one thing let's start with the
all output clear so that I don't have to
again do individually so I'll just run
these two lines of code okay now so yeah
so we have the default graph and as of
now there are no operations so there is
a method called get underscore
operations which which will kind of
display or show what are the various
operations that have been performed on
the graph so as I said to start with
there have no operations being performed
so when I try to display it's empty
there are no nothing is there no
operations okay now let's see what
happens when we slowly step by step
start writing or building the graph so
my first step may be to create a
constant okay remember in the previous
example I have shown you how to create a
constant in the most simple or the
simplest way which is like constant and
then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same I can say a is
equal to name and x y z I can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for Simplicity
because there is a purpose why I am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
I'm using this but otherwise this having
additionally a name usually doesn't add
much value all right so let's create a
constant I created a constant and now
let us see what's going on in the graph
so I will just say operations is equal
to get operations and if you see here
now you remember here it was blank now
you see the first operation is showing
up and this a that's the reason I put
here so it is showing as a and it says
that okay you have performed an
operation and there is a constant you
have created a constant okay all right
so let's move on let's say we want to
create a second constant and this is B
so if I see what does what are the
operations list of operations that have
been performed you see here there are
two of them so you have operation a
which is a constant then you have an
operation B another constant you recall
we in the term operation here is not
very intuitive right so we are just
creating constants or numbers or
variables and it is saying it's an
operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say I want to create a
third operation and that is basically
adding which is this is a real operation
in normal sense as well so let's say I'm
creating C which which is adding a and b
and the C value obviously will be a plus
b okay now if we want to see what is in
C and we say C to see here it is not
showing 30 it just says it is a tensor
and it is of type in 32 right because we
have not executed the graph we are still
only building the graph I hope this
makes it easy to understand okay so we
are just building the graph we have till
we do remember till we do a session and
run a particular operation you're not
actually executing anything okay you're
just building the graph all right so now
let us see what are the operations we
have done a b and now C so you will see
there are three of them A B and C okay
now let's do one more operation which is
D and here I am doing multiplication
remember we did a TF dot add now I'll do
TF dot multiply and I am multiplying A
and B and I'm calling this operation as
D so a has uh I think uh 10 and B has 20
so D will be at actually 200 when we
execute it right now it is just a tensor
and it is of shape in 32 okay and once
again we can see what are the operations
A B C D and let's do one last operation
here which is e which is once again
multiplication of c and d now that c has
30 which is a plus b and d has 200 which
is a into B so now C into D will be 30
into 200 which is which is equal to 6000
but as we have seen earlier that
multiplication will not happen right now
so now you have built a fairly simple
but operation graph which consists of a
b c d e one two three four five
operations okay so you built a small
it's not a very complicated one but a
simple graph now you need to execute
these operations so what you need to do
you need to create a session okay so
says dot TF is equal to session and then
you can run these session print says dot
run e now am I missing something do I
have to initialize the variables that's
a question for you think and tell me do
I have to initialize the variables then
remember I ran one piece of code I think
you must have got the answer I don't
have to because I am just using all
constants here I have not used any
variable here right so I don't have to
write execute that piece of code to
initialize the variables so I can just
create a session and run any of the
operations that I want to run so in this
case I am running session e operation e
right this operation e now I can
actually run individually instead of
doing directly E I could have run only a
or I could have run B and so on and so
forth but in this case I have run e
which in turn will do all the required
computations which is for example
assigning the value to A and B and C
doing the multiple education and so on
all those operations will be performed
which are required to do the computation
of e okay now there is a small piece of
code that you can use to find out what
are the various operations that are
there in this particular graph in this
case of course it was very easy very
straightforward I have created ABCDE but
in normal programming in real life this
can sometimes help to see how what is
there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so I finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because I did not use
the width block so I need to close the
session as a good practice so I close
the session good so that's how the graph
Works uh I hope it was helpful in
understanding how variables and
constants and placeholders are created
in the previous example we saw and how
exactly you create a graph and then you
actually execute that graph that's the
way tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example and
take some real data from from outside
external data CSV file and try to solve
a classification problem for that let's
first go back to the slides and
understand what is the problem statement
and then we will come back so okay so
what is the case here we have some
census data and which has all these
features or variables like the age of a
person what class work class what is
this education what is this marital
status gender and so on and so forth so
there are a bunch of a bunch of features
that are available and we have to
basically classify or not classify we
have to build a model for classifying
whether the income of this person is
above 50k or below 50k okay so there is
actually a label data available we will
then try to build a model and then see
what is the accuracy so that this is a
typical machine learning problem
actually but as I said tensorflow can be
used for doing machine learning as well
so we will as a simple example we will
take a machine learning so this is how
the high level the code looks and in
tensorflow programming we also take help
of regular python libraries like for
example it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data set so all
that can be done using regular
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
cited learn and so on so we use that and
then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow right main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be use saying I'll explain
what is in this slide but before that I
wanted to just show you what is the API
that we will be using so we will be
using the estimator API we will be using
the estimator API to create a classifier
what is known as a linear classifier now
in order to do that you need to prepare
the data and you need to prepare the
data into a certain structure or format
and the API itself needs to be fed in a
certain way so that is exactly what we
are doing before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but I will take you into
jupyter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a CSV
file and then there is a income bracket
is one of the columns which basically is
our Target that is what is used that is
the label rather but this doesn't have
numeric values so it has the income so
we need convert that into binary values
either 0 or 1. so that's what we are
doing here and then we are splitting
using psychic learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
psychic learn people some of you who are
familiar with machine traditional
machine learning and you have done
machine learning in Python using
scikit-learn will immediately recognize
this this is a SQL Earnest scikit log
and there is a readily available method
to split the data into training and test
that's what we are doing here and then
you need to create what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the API estimator
API that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are
different ways of creating the feature
columns for numeric values and for
categorical values or rather for
continuous values and categorical values
okay so that's what has been two types
we are doing here we will see again in
the code as well and then you create
your model so this is basically model is
equal to TF dot estimator linear
classify and then you're feeding the
feature columns and also subsequently
you will call the training by passing
the input function and you specify how
many iterations to be done for the
training process and again this is all
typical machine learning process so
there is nothing specific for tensorflow
here and then you evaluate your model
because this is classification model so
you can again take help of the
scikit-learn to test the accuracy and
get the reports evaluation perform the
evaluation and get the report like this
one right so this is the classification
report and you will see what is the
Precision recall F1 score and so on
again this is the standard machine
learning process all right so that's
pretty much as far as the code here is
concerned once again again let me take
you into our lab and we will get started
with this particular code now let me
clear out the outputs so that you can
step by step you can see the output so
this is our data and
um we will actually this is just a
display here the code starts from here
so before even we start with our
tensorflow part of it as I mentioned we
now remember in the previous examples
the data was kind of cooked up
internally we created some data and we
were using it right the constants
variables and so on here is a real life
example so you are actually getting data
from outside so you know before we get
into tensorflow this is actually regular
python code so we are using pandas for
example to create our data frame so we
will import pandas and then we will
basically read our file into a pandas
data frame and this is how the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you you about six readings or
observations five or six observations
and then you can take a look at how your
data is looking so for example you have
age work class education and so on and
so forth and you see here this last
column income underscore bracket it says
whether the income is greater than 50k
or less than 50k so this cannot be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our model or or uh you know so that's
the reason we need to convert this this
will not be understood right so this
needs to be converted uh saying okay
maybe less than 50k 0 and greater than
50k is one so that conversion needs to
be done before we feed it into our model
so that's what we are going to do as we
move forward so this is the code for
doing that okay so we take this and then
we Define a function and then we run
that function so now we have wherever it
is less than 50k it will have 0 and
greater than 50k it will have 1 so we
have now updated the data then the next
part is to split our data into training
and test data set so how are we going to
do that we again will take the standard
python Library which is scikit-learn SQL
on library and we use an existing
function there which is a train test
split and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into I'm
sorry I need to run this and then this
okay sorry about that so once I run this
what is what are we doing here again
those are familiar with scikit-learn
will immediately recognize I am
splitting this into test and train I'm
saying test size is 30 so 30 of the data
should go into test and training should
have 70 okay so that's all we are doing
0.3 indicates thirty percent so you can
again this can be individual preferences
some people do it like 50 50 some people
2080 and in our case we are doing 70 30.
so training is 70 and test is 30.
all right so we have so far we've been
doing regular
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is we will be using the API called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and run the model for
training so the next few lines will be
doing that quick look at before we even
get in once again into the tensorflow
code so this is just showing us what are
the various columns names of The Columns
of this data Okay so so that is what is
shown here and this is more for when I
was writing the code I could copy paste
from here that's the reason I this line
of code is there instead of typing in
these values okay good so now is where
the actual tensorflow action starts so I
import tensorflow and now I will use
this feature column functionality to
create my feature columns and there is a
certain construct how you create the
feature columns again probably the
details of that is out of scope here but
just that you need to know that we need
to create feature columns and the way
you create feature columns for
continuous values and for categorical
values is slightly different and that's
the reason you have two different blocks
okay so for categorical values you need
to use what is known as TF dot feature
column dot categorical column with
vocabulary list and again within this
again there are two ways in which you
can create for categorical values one is
a vocabulary list where you know how
many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case if there are
let's say a finite number of values for
a given column then you use a column
with vocabulary list okay so and then
you say what is the name of the column
and what are the possible values so in
this case male and female now there will
be situations where the the values that
this column can have okay first of all
it is a categorical column that means it
can have names or some non-numerical
values but the number of values is
probably unknown or undefined so for
example occupation now occupation can
have any value it can be self-employed
it can be software Professional Bank a
teacher doctor so so many possibilities
are there and we don't know in the given
data how many occupations have been
listed right so so that is where you use
what is known as categorical column with
hash bucket and you specify the hash
bucket size so what it what this says is
there can be a maximum of 1000 such
values so typically if you give a safe
number safely large number so that you
don't run out of these number of
occupations so I think thousand is a
safe number I don't think there will be
more than thousand occupations in a
given data so that's the idea behind it
but that's a judgment call we need to
take what should be the size of this
bucket size right hash bucket size so
these are two different types for
categorical values for creating the
feature column so we will execute this
for all the categorical columns
obviously you need to know the type of
the columns and that is where if you see
right at the beginning this information
was provided what is the data type and
you see here the column name and what
whether it is continuous or categorical
this information is provided in the
Census Data wherever we pick the Census
Data from by the way this was picked
from online from a government website
and we stored locally so on that website
it is mentioned the details of this data
were mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical method for the categorical
type of columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use what is
known as feature column dot numeric
column okay so these are all continuous
or numeric values like age education
number capital gain Capital loss hours
per work these are all numerical values
or continuous values right so you just
say TF dot feature underscore column dot
numeric underscore column and then give
the name of the column so once you do
that think I have executed the previous
one yeah this one now so your feature
columns are ready and uh you need to
basically create a vector of all these
columns and we call that as feet
underscore calls which is which is like
a short form for feature columns now as
you I have seen I've mentioned earlier
also there are two things that are
needed one is the feature columns and
another is the input function so feature
columns to First create the model and
then to train the model you need to
create an input function so now we have
the feature columns ready next is to
create an input function and there is a
certain way in which you need to this
construct is pretty much very common
construct so we will use that so the
input function takes these X and Y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the X strain is the X
values of the training data set and Y
train is the labels of the training data
set so that's what we are using here
extreme White train and then we specify
what is the batch size batch size you
remember I mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochses again uh
probably the definition is not required
here but at a very high level how many
times the entire data has to be passed
through the model right so if you have
thousand records and you pass all the
Thousand records three times for
training purpose then you call that as
three epochs right so there is a
difference between the batch size and
epochs so when let's say we have
thousand records and you're saying batch
size is 100 that means there will be 10
batches right so if you take 10 batches
then that is one Epoch gets completed
okay then you the training obviously
doesn't get completed in one round okay
so you need to pass this data again
maybe a second time or a third time till
you get the right accuracy that is known
as epochs okay again if you need more
details about this you may have to go
through the machine learning tutorial I
think it becomes much clearer okay so
you have your input function as well
let's execute that okay and now we are
ready to create the use the API right so
what will we do we will create the
linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linear classifier and this
guy needs feature columns right so
that's why we created we did all that so
much of manipulations to create this
feature columns so we have feature
columns so we pass that and we create
our model there may be a few warnings
don't worry about that so we will just
ignore that and now we use that model
and we actually what we did is we
created an instance of the model we have
not really run anything we just created
a instance of the model now we will
create the node for training so model
dot train and this needs the input
function remember we we created the
input function so we need to pass the
input function and then we say the steps
is now telling how many iterations this
training has to be run so we are saying
5000 and this may be it will probably
take a little long so we will okay but
that's fine I think we will leave it
5000. sometimes if you have probably a
less powerful machine you can cut it
down to maybe 1000 or something like
that but in this case I have a fairly
powerful system so I think it shouldn't
take much long let's uh go ahead and
give couple of minutes for it to get
over okay so let us go back yeah I think
this is that you see here the the r
Glass has disappeared that means this
computation has done and yes okay this
is done right saving checkpoint for 5000
that means it is done so training is
done so now what we have to do we need
to do the evaluation so again this is a
standard machine learning method so a
methodology rather so training has done
has been done with the training data set
now you need to evaluate using your test
data set so that's what we are doing
here for example you see here x
underscore test is your the test data
set remember we used scikit-learn to
split the data into training and test
data set so X underscore test and a
quick question why are we not using Y
underscore test here like we did in case
of training obviously we are expecting
the model to predict the values y values
right so that's why we don't pass the Y
values here all right so let's execute
this for doing the evaluation all right
and then we put them in a proper format
because the output doesn't come out in a
proper format so we put it in list
format and then we can just check yeah
so this is done and we can check what is
the first element in this what is the
probabilities and so on so it's just a
quick way to see if the values are there
or not you can take any value here right
any element here all right now that the
testing is done what we need to do again
we will probably put them in some kind
of this is more of a formatting thing we
will just uh run through quickly and
then we will use once again scikit-learn
for finding out the accuracy and so on
because scikit-learn offers what is
known as the classification report
functionality so we will use that and
find out how well our model has
performed so you see here again people
with machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the Precision what is
the recall and F1 score this is pretty
much like you're getting like almost 85
percent accuracy which is pretty okay
and there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or user this is a linear classifier we
could do have used a non-linear
classifier and so on so again multiple
ways of doing it to increase the
accuracy but the idea here was to
quickly show you a piece of uh
tensorflow code and that's what we have
done here we have the original
tensorflow release of 1.0 and then they
came out with the 2.0 version and the
2.0 addressed so many things out there
that the 1.0 really needed so we start
talking about tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
I guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensor flow one to tensorflow 2. we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if I want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit X train y train and then your
validation data your x value y value and
your epics and your batch size all that
goes into the fit and you can see here
where that was all just compressed to
make it run easier you can just create a
model and do a fit on it and you only
have that last set of code on there so
it's automatic that's what they mean by
the eager so if you see the first part
you're like what the heck is all this
session thing going on that's tensorflow
1.0 and then when you get into 2.0 it's
just nice and clean if you remember from
the beginning I said cross on our list
up there
and cross is the high level API in
tensorflow 2.0 cross is the official
high level API of tensorflow 2.0 it has
incorporated across as tf.cross cross
provides a number of model building apis
such as sequential functional and
subclassing so you can choose a right
level of abstraction for your project
and uh we'll hopefully touch base a
little bit more on this sequential being
the most common form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic reverse
propagation neural network and then
those all come together into another
layer which is your neural network
reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into Karas
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently in the tensorflow cross setup
a third big change we're going to look
at is it in tensorflow 1.0 in order to
use TF layers as variables you would
have to write TF variable block so you'd
have to pre-define that in tensorflow 2
you just add your layers in under the
sequential and it automatically defines
them as long as they're flat layers of
course this changes a little bit as a
more complicated tensor you have coming
in but all of it's very easy to do and
that's what 2.0 does a really good job
of and here we have a little bit more on
the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow 1 asks you to do these
different layers and values if you look
at the scope and the default name you
start looking at all the different code
in there to create the variable scope
that's not even necessary until tensor
2.0 so you'd have to do one before you
do do what you see the code in 2.0 in
2.0 you just create your model it's a
sequential model and then you can add
all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the um
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our API cleanup and
the autograph in the API cleanup
tensorflow 1 you could build models
using TF Gans TF app TF contrib TF Flags
Etc and tensorflow 2 a lot of apis have
been removed and this is just they just
clean them up because people weren't
using them and they've simplified them
and that's your TF app your TF Flags
your TF logging are all gone
so there's those are three Legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our TF function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow
1-0 the python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the TF function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of TF
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph graph is not a picture of a person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph is what are all those lines
that are connecting different objects so
if you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using in
neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic Tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented API so this is
what you're working with you have your
TF cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your TF layers TF losses
TF metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross running your
estimators and then being able to swap
in different layers you can your losses
your metrics all of that is so built
into tensorflow makes it really easy to
use and then you can get down to your
low level TF API you have extensive
control over this you can put your own
formulas in there your own procedures or
models in there you could have it split
we talked about that earlier so with the
2.0 you can now have it split One
Direction where you do a linear
regression model and then go to the
other where it does a neural network and
maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it and then
it comes together into another layer
which is another neural network so you
can build these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around and most recently we have the TF
code can run on multiple platforms and
so you have your CPU which is basically
like on the computer I'm running on I
have eight cores and 16 dedicated
threads I hear they now have one out
there that has over a hundred cores uh
so you have your CPU running and then
you have your GPU which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
TPU setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models uh neural network kind
of setup so now you can export the TF
code and it can run on all kinds of
different platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture we
have you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with and
eighty percent of your time in data
science is spent pre-processing data
making sure it's loaded correctly and
everything looks right so the first
level in tensorflow is going to be your
read and pre-process data your TF data
feature columns
this is going to feed into your TF Cross
or your pre-made estimators and kind of
you have your tensorflow Hub that sits
on top of there so you can see what's
going on uh once you have all that set
up you have your distribution strategy
where are you going to run it are you
going to be running it on just your
regular CPU are you going to be running
it with the GPU added in like I have a
pretty high-end graphics card so it
actually grabs that GPU processor and
uses it or do you have a specialized TPU
set up in there that you paid extra
money for it could be if you're in later
on when you're Distributing the package
you might need to run this on some
really high processors because you're
processing at a server level for let's
say net you might be processing this at
a distribute you're Distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
Distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for a data fraud
analysis working with the banks you want
to be able to run this at a high speed
so that when you have hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person probably has a
credit card so when we're talking about
all those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is we were talking
about that earlier where it used to be
when you did one of these models it
wouldn't truncate the float numbers the
same and so a model going from one you
build the model on your machine in the
office and then you need to distribute
it and so we have our tensorflow serving
Cloud on premium that's what I was
talking about if you're like a banking
or something like that now they have
tensorflow Lite so you can actually run
a tensorflow on an Android or an iOS or
Raspberry Pi a little breakout board
there in fact they just came out with a
new one that has a built-in is this mini
TPU with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that talking about
an affordable way to beta test a new
product you have the tensorflow JS which
is for browser and node server so you
can get that out in the browser for some
simple computations that don't require a
lot of heavy lifting but you want to
distribute to a lot of endpoints and now
they also have other language bindings
so you can now create your tensorflow
back in save it and have it accessed
from C Java go C sharp rust r or from
whatever package you're working on so we
kind of have an overview of the
architecture and what's going on behind
the scenes and in this case what's going
on as far as Distributing it let's go
ahead and take a look at three specific
pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions so very basic
things you need to know and understand
when you're working with the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
Syntax for constant value d-type 9 shape
equals none name constant verify shape
equals false that's kind of the syntax
you're looking at and we'll explore this
with our hands on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do Z equals
tf.constant 5.2 name equals x d type is
a float that means that we're never
going to change that 5.2 is going to be
a constant value and then we have our
variables in tensorflow variables in
tensorflow are in memory buffers that
store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the ways you
can create a an array of ones for your
constants I'm not sure why you do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
and here we have V equals TF dot
variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.1s
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice two
by three array that's filled with ones
and then of course you can go in there
in their variables so you can change
them it's a tensor so you have full
control over that and then you of course
have uh sessions in tensorflow a session
in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate to the
nodes and remember when we're talking a
graph or graph x we're talking about all
that information then goes through all
those arrows and whatever computations
they have they take it to the next node
and you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as TF if we do x
equals a TF dot constant of 10 we do y
equals a TF constant of 2.0 of 20.0 and
then you can do Z equals TF dot variable
and it's a TF dot add X comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your TF
Global variables initializer with TF
session as session you can do a session
run knit and then you print the session
run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today I'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then I'll use specifically the Jupiter
Notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook the Jupiter lab which is just a
Jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with Jupiter notebook pycharm whatever
it is you're going to use in here you
have your spider and your QT console for
different programming environments the
thing to note it's kind of hard to see
but I have my main Pi 3 6. right now
when I was writing this tensorflow works
in Python version three six if you have
python version three seven or three
eight you're probably going to get some
errors in there might be that they've
already updated it and I don't know it
now you have an older version
but you want to make sure you're in a
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in Anaconda I can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and and pip in your tensorflow or
if you're in Anaconda you can do a conda
install tensorflow to make sure it's in
your package so let's just go ahead and
dive in and bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
I just love the fact I can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what I'm working
on making it really easy to adjust a
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new Python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it Untitled let's
go ahead and import import tensorflow as
TF at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick no errors yay no
errors I
I do that whenever I do my imports
because I unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know what
version we're working with and we can do
that simply by using the version command
and tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the TF
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and you know it always confuses me
because sometimes you do tf.version for
one thing you do TF dot underscore
version underscore for another thing uh
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and I did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array a
equals tf.constant and we're just going
to put the array right in there four
three six one we can run this and now
that is what a is equal to and if we
want to just double check that remember
we're in Jupiter notebook where you can
just put the letter a and it knows that
that's going to be print otherwise you'd
run you'd surround it in print and you
can see it's a TF tensor it has the
shape the type and the and the array on
here it's a two by two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
ahead and create a variable and this is
also going to be a two by two array and
if we go ahead and print the V out we'll
run that and sure enough there's our TF
variable in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here I could create
another tensor and we'll make it a
constant this time
and we'll go and put that in over here
we'll have b t f constant and if we go
and print out V and B I'm going to run
that and this is an interesting thing
that always that happens in here you'll
see right here when I print them both
out what happens it only prints the last
one unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and Surround V with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have we have the
three one five two which is a variable
and this is just a flat constant so it
comes up as a TF tensor shape two kind
of two and that's interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a TF variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing I want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the V and
with the constant we have a lowercase C
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work uh so those are a couple little
things to note in here and just like any
other array in math we can do like a
concatenate or concatenate the different
values here and you can see we can take
a b concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out you'll see right here we end up
with a tensor so let's put it in as a
constant nut as a variable
and you have your array 4 3 7 8 and 6145
is concatenated the two together and
a couple things on this our axes equals
one this means we're doing the columns
so if you had a longer array like right
now we have an array that is like you
know has a shape one whatever it is two
comma two
axes zero
is going to be your first one and axis
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what I'm talking about it's
very clear and this is I'll tell you
what I spend a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction I'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
Matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes axis one you know
zero one two that's going to be our
columns and if you can do columns then
we also can do rows and that is simply
just changing the concatenate we'll just
grab this one here and copy it we'll do
the whole thing over
control copy
Ctrl V and changes from axis one
to axis zero and if we run that you'll
see that now we concatenate by row as
opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output in this really you want to
look at the output sometimes just to
make sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format I find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than understanding what's
going on because conceptually your mind
just just too many dimensions sometimes
the second thing I want you to notice is
this says a numpy array so tensorflow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as Python's concerned and so you
can treat you can treat this output like
a numpy array because it is just that
it's going to be a numpy array another
thing that comes up uh more than you
would think is filling uh one of these
with zeros or ones and so you can see
here we just create a tensor tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
Jupiter so I can just type out tensor
and I run this you can see I have a nice
array of the shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things I want to
highlight here is integer 32. if I go to
the tensorflow data types I want you to
notice how we have float 16 float 32
float 64 complex if we scroll down
you'll see the integer down here 32. the
reason for this is that we want to
control how many bits are used in the
Precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform so what would happen is I might
run it on this computer where python
goes does a float to indefinite however
long it wants to and then we can take it
but we want to actually say hey we don't
want that high Precision we want to be
able to run this on any computer and so
we need to control whether it's a TF
float 16. in this case we did an integer
32.
we could also do this as a float so if I
run this as a float32 that means this
has a 32-bit Precision you'll see Zero
Point whatever and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
you might ask yourself why would I want
zeros and ones and your first thought
might be to initiate a new tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform set of ones or zeros you're
dealing with a lot of bias so be very
careful about starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros on the other
hand uh I use this for masking you can
do a lot of work with masking you can
also have it might be that one tenths a
row is masked you know zero is is false
one is true or whatever you want to do
it
um and so in that case you do want to
use the zeros and ones and there are
cases where you do want to initialize it
with all zeros or all ones and then swap
in different numbers as a as the tensor
learns so it's another form of control
but in general you see zeros and ones
you usually are talking about a mask
over another array and just like in
numpy you can also do reshapes so if we
take our remember this is shaped three
comma four maybe we want to swap that to
four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
control V let me run that and you'll see
that the the order of these is now
switched instead of four across now we
have three across and four down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones and I'm going to
change the ones to TF dot random uniform
uh and we'll go and just take off well
we'll go and leave that I'm going to run
this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441 and
this way you can actually see how the
reshape looks a lot different uh 0.04
1.15.71 and then instead of having this
one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what I was talking about
sometimes you feel a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random.uniform is one of the
ways to do that now I just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types one of the things that
comes up of course is recasting your
data
so if we have a d-type float32 we might
want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
I know one of the projects I've worked
on ended up when you do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
um and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot of or then
convert it to an integer was one way to
round it off kind of
the cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this and we can take the
same tensor and we'll go ahead and
create a as an integer and so we're
going to take this tensor we're going to
tf.cast it and if we print
tensor and then we're going to go ahead
and print
our
tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when I'm actually programming I
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it uh in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what I'm
working on
and you can see here we took a float32
4.6 4.2 and so on and it just converts
it right down to a integer value
sorry integer 32 setup and remember we
talked about a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and I just did
four comma 3 on the reshape up here and
we talked about axis 0 axis one one of
the things that is important to be able
to do is to take one of these variables
we'll just take this last one tensor as
integer
and I want to go ahead and transpose it
and so I can do we'll do a
equals TF dot transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if I print the A out and we run
this
you'll see it's the same array but we've
flipped it so that our columns and rows
are flipped this is the same as
reshaping so when you transpose you're
just doing a reshape what's nice about
this is that if you look at the numbers
The Columns when we went up here and we
did the reshape they kind of rolled down
to the next row so you're not
maintaining the structure of your Matrix
so when we do a reshape up here they're
similar but they're not quite the same
and you can actually go in here and
there's settings in the reshape that
would allow you to turn it into a
transform
uh so when we come down here it's all
done for you and so there are so many
times you have to transpose your digits
that this is important to know that you
can just do that you can flip your rows
and columns rather quickly here and just
like numpy you can also do multiple your
different math functions we'll look at
multiplication and so we're going to
take matrix multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839 and we'll put in a vector
v 4 comma two and we could have done
this where they matched where this was a
two by two array but instead we're going
to do just a two by one array and the
code for that is your TF dot mat mole so
Matrix multiplier and we have a times V
and if we go ahead and run this up let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen The Matrix math this is five times
four plus eight times two
three times four plus nine times two
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now I know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the Matrix or your Matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as Computing
um
different models or linear regression
stuff like that one of the things
is to note is that just like in numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our TF math
and if we go in here we have functions
we have our cosines absolute angle all
of that's in here so all of these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull oh let's do some
multiplication that's always good we'll
stick with our av our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bitwise
multiplication and we'll create an AV
which is a times B let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the 4 2 and the 5839 and it
produces 20 32 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times five is
twenty four times eight is uh 32 that's
where those numbers come from
we can also quickly create an identity
Matrix
which is basically your main values on
the diagonal being ones and zeros across
the other side let's go ahead and take a
look and see what that uh
looks like we can do let's do this uh
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a DOT shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick print
we'll do rows oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this you can see we have
three rows two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity Matrix
the scripts
the script for that hit a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and D type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module available but
we do want to start looking at this as a
prediction model and seeing how it
functions so we're going to move on to a
more of a
direct setup where you can actually see
the full tensorflow in use for that
let's go back and create a new setup
and we'll go in here new Python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because I like to do that
hopefully I made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being a series
of numpy arrays you got your math
equations and different things that go
into them we're going to start building
a full
set up as far as the numpy so you can
see how Cara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works the
first thing you want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports date times warning SCI Pi SCI Pi
is your
maths or the back end scientific math
warnings because whenever we do a lot of
this you have older versions newer
versions and so sometimes when you get
warnings you want to go ahead and just
suppress them we'll talk about that if
it comes up on this particular setup and
of course date time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as PD
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
Seaborn for our graphics and the Seaborn
as SNS is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as MPL
and then of course we're going to import
our matplot library pipelot as PLT and
right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors patch Force Edge
color equals true the style we're going
to use the 538 style you can look this
all up there's when you get into matplot
Library into Seabourn there are so many
options in here it's just kind of nice
to make it look pretty when we start the
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take and we
have our mplrc we're going to put a
patch Ed color dim Gray Line with again
this is all part of our Graphics here in
our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell node interactivity
equals last expression uh here we are PD
for pandas options display Max columns
so we don't want to display more than
50. and then our matplot library is
going to be inline this is a Jupiter
notebook thing the matplot library
inline and then warnings we're going to
filter our warnings and we're just going
to ignore warnings that way when they
come up we don't have to worry about
them not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background so
that's a little back end kind of stuff
then we want to go ahead and do is we
want to go ahead and import our specific
packages that we're going to be working
with which is under Karas now remember
cross kind of sits on tensorflow so when
we're importing cross and the sequential
model we are in effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it we just
brought in the math probably should have
put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our slide there was three
different options let me just flip back
over there so we can have a quick uh
recall on that and so in Cross we have
sequential functional and subclassing so
remember those three different setups in
here we talked about earlier and if you
remember from here we have uh sequential
where it's going one tensorflow layer at
a time you go kind of look at think of
it as going from left to right or top to
bottom or whatever Direction it's going
in but it goes in One Direction all the
time where functional can have a very
complicated graph of directions you can
have the data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor all those kinds of
things and then subclassing is really
the really complicated one where now
you're adding your own subclasses into
the tensor to do external computations
right in the middle of like a huge flow
of data but we're going to stick with
sequential it's not a big jump to go
from sequential to functional but we're
running a sequential tensorflow and
that's what this first import is here we
want to bring in our sequential and then
we have our layers and let's talk a
little bit about these layers this is
where cross and tensorflow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built so from Cross we have
layers import dents from Cross layers
import LST M when we talk about these
layers
across has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers the dense layer
is your standard neural network by
default it uses relu for its activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data uh
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is a cross website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in we can get down here and we
can look at let's see here we have our
layer activation our base layers
um activation layer weight layer weights
just a lot of stuff in here we have the
rayleu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers and our
dense layers we have an input layer a
dense layer and then we've added a more
customized one with the long-term
short-term memory layer and of course
you can even do your own custom layers
in Karas there's a whole functionality
in there if you're doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing Graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is so popular
it's open source and you have all these
tools right at your fingertips so from
Cross we're just going to import a
couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer and
then of course from sklearn our site kit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scaler for pre-editing
our data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv let's go ahead and take a
quick look at that this is in Open
Office it's just a standard you know we
can do excel whatever you're using for
your spreadsheet and you can see here we
have a number of columns a number of
rows that actually goes down to like 8
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row is kind of just a
random number put in going down probably
not something we're going to work with
the second row is Bandung I'm guessing
that's a reference for the profile if we
scroll to the bottom which I'm not going
to do because it takes forever to get
back up they're all the same the same
thing with the status the status is the
same we have a date so we have a
sequential order here
here is the jam which I'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our O3 CEO NO2 reading SO2
noco2 VOC and then some other numbers
here pm1 PM 2.5 pm4 pm10
without actually looking through the
data I mean some of this I can guess is
like temperature humidity I'm not sure
what the PMS are but we have a whole
slew of data here so we're looking at
air quality as far as an area and a
region and what's going on with our date
time stamps on there and so code wise
we're going to read this into a pandas
data frame so our data frame DF is a
nice abbreviation commonly used for data
frames equals pd.read CSV and then our
the path to it just happens to be on my
D drive separated by spaces and so if we
go ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in Jupiter I can take this and go
the other way make it real small so you
can see all the columns going across and
we get a full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the band done the date we have
a time stamp our O3 count Co and so
forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows we could
easily have done three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now I've talked about this all
the time so I know I've already said it
at least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together so we want to go ahead
and start with our date time let's come
in in two columns we have our date here
and we have our time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combine date
time that's our formula we're building
or we're going to submit our pandas data
frame and the tab name when we go ahead
and do this that's all of our
information that we want to go ahead and
create and then goes for Iron Range DF
shape 0. so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab a pin DF location I and here is our
date going in there and then return the
numpy array list tab d-types date time
64. that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead and do DF date time
equals combine date time and then I
always like to print we'll do DF head
just so we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this we now
have our setup button here and of course
it's edited on to the far right here's
our date time you can see the formats
changed uh so there's our we've added in
the date time column and we've brought
the date over and we've taken this
format here and it's an actual variable
with a zero zero zero on here well that
doesn't look good so we need to also
include the time part of this we want to
convert it into hourly data so let's go
ahead and do that to do that to finish
combining our date time let's go ahead
and create a a little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and forcing this into a date time
format and we can actually spend hours
just going through these conversions how
do you pull it from the pandas data
frame how do you set it up so I'm kind
of skipping through it a little fast
because I want to stay focused on
tensorflow and cross keep in mind this
is like 80 percent of your coding when
you're doing a lot of this stuff is
going to be reformatting these things
resetting them back up so that it looks
right on here and you know it just takes
time to to get through all that but that
is usually what the companies are paying
you for that's what the big bucks are
for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
um now remember we can select from DF
our different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped a couple of the
columns those ones I showed you earlier
they're just repetitive data so there's
nothing in there that exciting and then
we want to go ahead and we'll create a
second
data frame here just get rid of the DF
head and df2 is we're going to group by
date time and we're looking at the mean
value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 Co so now this is in the
same order as it was before and you'll
see the date time now has our zero zero
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together so there's a lot more
manageable and in the format we want and
in the right sequential order
and if we go back to there we go our air
quality you can see right here we're
looking at
um
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own date time column we can get rid
of those these are the different Columns
of information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist first thing I want to do is
get a description what am I looking at
and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there so you can get a
quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis and even
though we have our quantile information
in here we're going to dig a little
deeper into that we're going to
calculate the quantile for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable we'll see right
here q1 we can simply do the quantile
0.25 percent
which should match our 25 up here and
we'll be looking at the Min the Max and
we're just going to do this is basically
we're breaking this down for each uh
different
variable in there one of the things
that's kind of fun to do we're going to
look at that in just a second let me get
put the next piece of code in here I
clean out some of our
um we're going to drop a couple thing
our last rows and first row because
those have usually have a lot of null
values and the first row is just our
titles so that's important it's
important to drop those rows in here and
so this right here as we look at our
different quantiles again it's it's the
same you know we're still looking at the
25 quantile here we're going to do a
little bit more with this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through all of our columns and
this way we can look at each column
individually and so we'll just create a
q1 Q3 min max Min IQR Max IQR and
calculate the quantile of I of df2
we're basically doing the math that they
did up here but we're splitting it apart
that's all this is
and this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project I would probably spend
days and days going through what these
different values mean
one of the biggest data science uh
things we can look at that's important
is use your use your common sense you
know if you're looking at this data and
it doesn't make sense and you go back in
there and you're like wait a minute what
the heck did I just do at that point you
probably should go back and double check
what you have going on
now we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our O3 so we've broken it down we have
our q1 5.88 Q3 10.37 if we go back up
here here's our five eight we've rounded
it off
10.37s in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our Max IQR and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times IQR and the IQR is your Q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters and
this is all data science
as far as the hard math I'm really not
that we're actually trying to focus on
cross and tensorflow you still got to go
through all this stuff I told you eighty
percent of your programming is going
through and understanding what the heck
happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
um
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum IQR
that means something's going wrong there
and usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier so we want to go
ahead and find the minimum value if it's
less than the minimum minimum IQR it's
an outlier and if the max value is
greater than the max IQR we have an
outlier and that's all this is doing low
outliers found minimum value High
outlier is found really important
actually outliers are almost everything
in data sometimes sometimes you do this
project just to find the outliers
because you want to know crime detection
what are we looking for we're looking
for the outliers what doesn't fit a
normal business deal and then we'll go
ahead and throw in just threw in a lot
of code oh my goodness uh so we have if
your max is greater than IQR print
outlier is found what we want to do is
we want to start cleaning up these
outliers and so we want to convert we'll
do create a convert Nan x max IQR equals
Max underscore IQR men IQR equals Min
IQR so this is just saying this is the
data we're going to send that's all that
is in Python and if x is greater than
the max IQR and X is less than the Min
IQR x equals null we're going to set it
to null why because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else this not in
that Series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the Nan hum again we have x max
iqrs 100 percent Min iqrs Min IQR if x
is greater than Max IQR and X is less
than Min IQR again we're going to return
null value otherwise it's going to
remain the same value x x equals X
and you can see as we go through the
code if I equals our hum then we go
ahead and do this the that's a column
specific to humidity that's your hem
column then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the run a map on there and
convert the none hum you can see here
it's this is just clean up uh we run
we've found out that humidity probably
has some weird values in it we have our
outliers
that's all this is and so when we go
ahead and finish this and we take a look
at our outliers and we run this code
here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier 99.06 outliers have been
interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like these sensors
coming in they probably have a failed
sensor in there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then converting it
over and setting it up method linear
so we interpolate method linear is it's
going to fill that data in based on a
linear regression model of similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um
we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data how
do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on let's take the temp value and
we're going to go ahead and use a
logarithmic function on the temp value
and it's interesting because it's like
how do you how do you heck do you even
know to use logarithmic on the temp
value that's domain specific we're
talking about being an expert in air
care I'm not an expert in Air Care
um you know it's not what I go look at I
don't look at Air Care data in fact this
is probably the first Air Care data
setup I've looked at but the experts
come in there and they come to even say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially very variable on here so
we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts data analytics a lot of times
you're talking about somebody who is a
data analysis might be all the way using
a PhD level data science programming
level interfaces database manager that's
going to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey domain Air Care this
needs to be this is a skew because the
data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
um we have our uh we'll do a
distribution DF we'll create another
data frame from the temp values and then
from a data set from the log temp so we
can put them side by side and we'll just
go ahead and do a quick histogram and
this is kind of nice plot a figure
figure size here's our PLT from matplot
library and then we'll just do a
distribution underscore DF there's our
data frames this is nice because it just
integrates the histogram right into
pandas love pandas and this is a chart
you would send back to your data
analysis and say hey is this what you
wanted this is how the data is
converting on here as a data science
scientist the first thing I note is
we've gone from a 10 20 30 scale to 2.5
3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here we'll go ahead and split
our data up and this of course is any
good data scientists you want to have a
training set and a test set and we'll go
ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error and we'll have our
train size is 75 percent and the test
size is going to be of course the train
size minus the length of the data set
and then we can simply do train comma
test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size and then if we go and print
this let me just go ahead and run this
we can see how these values split it's a
nice split of 1298 and then 433 points
of value that are going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh converted an array of
values into a data set Matrix we're
going to create a little
um
set up in here we create our data set
our data set is going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data X and our data y
for Iron Range length of data set look
back minus one
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data and
take a look at the shape of it let me go
ahead and just put that code in here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our trainex our train Y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go and we run this piece of
code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of X 1296 comma 1
shape of Y train y Test X text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the X comes in
and we're only having a single value out
uh we want to predict what the next one
is that's what this little piece of code
is here for what are we looking for well
we want to look back one that's the um
then what we're going to train the data
with is yesterday's data yesterday says
Hey the humidity was at 97 what should
today's humidity be at if it's 97
yesterday is it going to go up or is it
going to go down today if 97 does it go
up to 100 what's going on there and so
our we're looking forward to the next
piece of data which says Hey tomorrow's
is going to you know today's humidity is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be that's all that is all that
is is stacking our data so that our Y is
basically X Plus 1 or X could be y minus
1.
and then a couple things to note is our
X data we're only dealing with the one
column but you need to have it in a
shape that has it by The Columns so you
have the two different numbers and since
we're doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem and the reason is is that we
have what they call a Time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer so we're going
to add another reshape on here let me
just go down here and put it into the
next cell and so we want to reshape the
input array in the form of sample time
step features
we're only looking at one feature
and I mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am I getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on so we're going
to do is we're going to add one more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 12.99 we added the one
dimension and then we have our train X
shape one and this could have depends
again on how far back in the long
short-term memory you want to go that is
what that piece of code is for and that
reshape is and you can see the new shape
is now one uh 12.99 one one versus the
1299 one and then the other part of the
shape 432 one one again this is our TR
our X in and of course our test X and
then our Y is just a single column
because we're just doing one output that
we're looking for so now we've done our
80 percent
um you know that's all the the writing
all the code reformatting our data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit the lstm
neural network and if we're going to do
that the first thing we need is we're
going to need to go ahead and create a
model and we'll do this sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order that means we have if
you have two layers the layers go from
layer one to Layer Two or layer 0 to
layer one this is different than
functional functional allows you to
split the data and run two completely
separate models and then bring them back
together we're doing just sequential on
here and then we decided to do the long
short term memory and we have our input
shape which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck is this
model coming from what kind of models do
we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there uh because we're going to
do two models and the next model is
going to go ahead and we're going to do
dents so we have model equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the Imports oops there we
go our cross this is it right here
here's our importing a dense model and
here's our importing an lstm now just
about every tensorflow model uses dense
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error where it does reverse propagation
to program the model so any of your
neural networks you've already looked at
that Lex and says here's the error and
sends the error backwards that's what
this is the long short term memory is a
little different the real question that
we want to look at right now is where do
you find these models what kind of
models do you have available and so for
that let's go to the Cross website which
is across.io if you go under API slash
layers and I always have to do a search
just search for cross API layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your Activation so a lot of
your layers you can switch how it
activates relu which is like your
smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu your
sigmoid all the way up to softmax soft
plus all these different choices as far
as how those are set up and what we want
to do is we want to go ahead and if you
scroll down here you'll see your core
layers and here is your dense layer so
you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer this is your your kind of your one
setup on there that's most common uh
convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing uh we have pooling layers so as
you have the layers come together
um usually bring them down into a single
layer although you can still do like
Global Max pulling 3D and there's just I
mean this list just goes on and on
there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for and figure out
what's going to work best for you
as far as which project you're working
on long short term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text what if someone says the what
comes after the uh The Cat in the Hat
little kids book there
starts programming it and so you really
want to know not only what's going on
but it's going to be something that has
a history the history behind it tells
you what the next one coming up is now
once we've built all our different you
know we built our model we've added our
different layers we went in there play
with it remember if you're in functional
you can actually link these layers
together and they Branch out and come
back together if you do a uh the sub
set up then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming in linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model as part of your
functional split and then have that come
back together with other things so we're
going to go ahead and compile your model
this brings everything together we're
going to put in what the losses which
we'll use the mean squared error and
we'll go ahead and use the atom
Optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any side kit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model so what are we doing in
here we're going to send in our train X
our train y we're going to decide how
many epics we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this I'm
guessing it'll probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine our
batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it if you're
in data analytics you might try to know
what this number is as a data scientist
where I haven't had the PHD level math
that says this is why you want to use
this particular batch size you kind of
play with this number a little bit you
can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
on what you're doing and there's a
number of other settings on here we did
verbose two I'd have to actually look
that up to tell you what verbose means I
think that's actually the default on
there if I remember correctly there's a
lot of different settings when you go to
fit it the big ones are your epic and
your batch size those are what we're
looking for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times through all the data so if you
have a huge data set this is the point
where you're kind of wondering oh my
gosh is this going to finish tomorrow
if I'm running this on a single machine
and I have a terabyte terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and I'm
running a terabyte of data into this you
know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations but you got a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will the
process on there more across multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
uh you know if you're retraining this
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to note where that error zone is so
you don't have to do all the extra
processing of course if you're going to
build a model we want to go ahead and
run a prediction on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction and remember we have our
training test set and our test set or
the we have the
trainx and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test X and our test y going in there so
we can test to see how good it did
uh and we come in here we have you'll
see right here we go ahead and do our
train predict equals model predict train
X
and test predict model predict Test X
why would we want to run the prediction
on trainx well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data this never C
the model's never seen before and one of
the things we can do we go ahead and
invert the predictions this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and NP
exponential M1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential M1
for train Y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um again reformatting the data so that
we can it all matches and then we want
to go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train Y and train
predict and again we're just um this is
just feeding the data through so we can
compare it and the same thing with the
test
and let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see we're doing but the answer really
helps to zoom in so we have a train
score which is
2.40 of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong at that point you got to go back
and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing when you're going out
and quoting your publishing this you're
saying hey how good is my model it's the
test score that you're showing people
this is what it did on my test data that
the model had never seen before this is
how good my model is and a lot of times
you actually want to put together like a
little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction and standard deviation
of data set 3.16 is less than 4.5
4-0 I'd have to go back and we're up
here if you remember we did the square
means error this is standard deviation
that's why these numbers are different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about uh 3.16 is less than 4.40
model is good enough we're saying hey
this is this model is valid we have a
valid model here so we can go ahead and
go with that and along with putting a
formal print out of there we want to go
ahead and plot what's going on
uh and this we just want a pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when I walk into a meeting and I'm
dealing with a number of people they
really don't want these numbers they
don't want to say hey what's I mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are you might be dealing with
a number of different departments head
of sales might not works with standard
deviation or have any idea what that
really means number wise and so at this
point we really want to put it in a
graph so we have something to display
and with displaying you gotta remember
that we're looking at the data today
going into it and what's going to happen
tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
NP MP like data set train predict plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um the data groups as we like them and
then putting the data in there is what's
going on here so we have our train
predict plot which is going to be our
look back our length plus look back
we're just it's going to equal train uh
try and predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
I put it in here double no let's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
um didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets uh test predict plot length
prediction set up on there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a Time axes
always nice to have your time set on
there set that to the time array
time axes lap all this is setting up the
time variable for the bottom and then we
have a lot of stuff going on here as far
as setting up our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here our main plot we have
two different plots going on here the
ispu going up in the data and the ispu
here with all these different settings
on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot I mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure PLT or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there and so we take and if you go
through the code piece by piece which
we're not going to do we're going to do
the the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set we're going to
plot the train predict plot that's what
we just created we're going to make that
orange and we'll label it train
prediction test predict plot we're going
to make that red and label it test
prediction and so forth set our ticks up
let's actually just put ticks time axes
gets its ticks the little little marks
that are going along the axes that kind
of thing and let's take a look and see
what these graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output and you say hey this
is what we're looking at here's our
original data in blue
here's our training prediction you can
see that it trains pretty close to what
the data is up there
I would also probably put a like a
little little time stamp and do just
right before and right after where we go
from a train to test prediction and you
can see with the test prediction the
data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set looked like behind it
and how it differs and then we can just
isolate that here on the right that's
all this is is just the test prediction
on the right uh and it's you know
there's you'll see what the original
data set there's a lot of Peaks we're
missing and a lot of lows were missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty it does pretty good it's
pretty right on you can get a good idea
what to expect for your ispu and so from
this we would probably publish it and
say hey this is what you expect and this
is our area of this is a range of error
that's the kind of thing I put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
sales are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice you
kind of flatten the um
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
um is this model here this is what this
is all about we work through all of
those pieces all the tensorflows and
that is to build this sequential model
and we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never it never
verges into a usable model so if you
have like 30 different layers in here
there's a good chance you might crash it
kind of thing so don't go too haywire on
that and that you kind of learn as you
go again it's domain knowledge and also
starting to understand all these
different layers and what they mean
the data
analytics behind those layers is
something that your data analysis
professional would come in and say this
is what we want to try
but I tell you as a data scientist a lot
of these basic setups are common and I
don't know how many times uh working
with somebody and they're like oh my
gosh if I only did a tangent H instead
of a relu activation I worked for two
weeks to figure that out well as a data
science I can run it through the model
in you know five minutes instead of
spending two weeks doing the the math
behind it so that's one of the
advantages of data scientists is we do
it from programming side in a data
analytics is going to look for it how
does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course with any data
science putting out a pretty graph so
that your shareholders again we want to
take and reduce the information down to
something people can look at and say oh
that's what's going on they can see
stuff what's going on as far as the
dates and the change in the ispu
now let's talk a little bit about a
recurrent neural networks so neural
networks are of different types we have
CNN we have RNN a n and so on now rmn is
one type of neural network RNN stands
for recurrent neural network the
networks like CNN and an are feed
forward Network which means that the
information pretty much only goes from
left to right or from front to back
whichever way you call it whereas in
case of recurrent neural network there
will be some information traveling
backwards as well so that is why it is
known as recurrent neural network and
each of these types have a specific
application so for example convolutional
neural networks or CNN are very good for
doing image processing and object
detection using for video and images
whereas recurrent neural networks are
pretty good for doing NLP or speech
recognition and so on okay so for the
next few minutes we will kind of focus
on recurrent neural networks and we will
see an example of how we can use RNN to
do a Time series analysis so in a
typical neural network this is how it
looks right so where you have a neuron
and then the inputs are coming to the
neuron and then you have an output which
goes to other neurons in the other
layers in case of recurrent neural
network what happens is you have the
inputs let's say at a given point in
time but then a part of the previous
output also gets fed in along with the
inputs for the given time now this can
be little confusing so let's see if we
can take a little expanded view of this
so this is another view of one single
neuron which is what is known as in an
unfolded manner okay so if we are
getting inputs or data over a period of
time then this is how the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say T minus 1 an input of x t minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of Y T minus 1 then the next instant
which is x t at a time T right there is
an input of x t and then there is an
output of y t so this is a single neuron
but is displayed in an unfolded way so
this is like expanding it over a period
of time so let's start with this part
here this particular neuron gets an
input at at an instant T minus 1 let's
say time is equal to T minus 1 it gets
an input of x t minus 1 and it gives an
output of Y T minus then when we go to
the instant T here it gets an input of x
t and it also additionally gets an input
from this previous time frame T minus 1.
so this y t minus 1 gets fed here and
that results in YT all right then when
we go to the time t plus 1 there is an
input of x t minus 1 at that given time
plus the input from the previous time
frame which is a time frame of T that
also gets fed in here and then we get an
output of y t plus 1 okay so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from T minus 1 to t plus
1 and unlike a regular feed forward
neuron which only gets X in this case
the input is X and also another input
which is coming from the previous time
frame and that is what this Loop is in
this on the left hand side diagram this
Loop is indicating that okay so on the
right hand side it is represented in an
unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame T for example is not
only x t which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame T but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this y y t
minus 1 is also being fed as an input
that is the key differentiator here okay
similarly at the instant t plus 1 it is
getting a normal input of x t plus 1
plus this y t is actually being fed here
and then the output comes as y t plus
one okay so this is the construct of a
recurrent neural network now recurrent
neural networks again can be of
different subtypes it can be one to one
one to many many to one and many to many
depending on what kind of application we
want to use one of the examples is like
the stock price so you're feeding so
there is only one input only thing is it
is spread over a period of time so
you're feeding the stock price input
that is what comes here as an input and
you get an output which is again the
stock price which is probably predicted
over the next uh two days three days or
10 days or whatever so the number of
outputs and inputs is the same there is
only one input there is only one output
only thing is it is spread over a time
so variables are not many then you have
one to many so there is one input but
you are expecting multiple outputs what
is an example of this let's say you want
to caption an image so how do you want
to do that what is the input that will
go here is just an image which is one
input but what is output you are looking
for you are looking for a phrase maybe
right not just a word but a phrase so
it's like cat is sitting on a mat right
so the image is there is only one image
which consists of the cat sitting on a
mat but the output or like maybe three
or four words which is saying the cat is
sitting on a mat so this is one too many
right then you can have many to one
examples of this are like you're feeding
some text and you want to know the
output whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you're looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text May consist of words or
lines or whatever so that is what is the
multiple inputs but the output all it
says is the sentiment is positive it is
just one output or the sentiment is
negative just one output right so this
is minute over then we have many to many
so what is an example of this let's say
you want to do some translation so how
do you do a translation you feed in a
sentence maybe in a particular language
English and then you want another a
sentence actually in another language so
that is like there are multiple inputs
one sentence can consist of multiple
words and the output also is a sentence
consisting of multiple words all right
so how do we Implement RNN this is an
example of implementing an RNN for a
particular use case so in our particular
example we have the data about milk
production over a few months and using
RNN we want to predict because this is
time series analysis so RNN is good to
do time series analysis so using RNN we
want to predict what will be the milk
production in the future so let us see
how we can do that I will first take you
through quickly through the slides and
then I will actually run this in Jupiter
notebook the code I will run it in the
jupyter notebook so this is how it looks
the code looks so while the suspenser
flow you still use the standard python
libraries like numpy and pandas and even
matplotlib to do some initial processing
getting the data processing it cleaning
it whatever all that can be still done
in within the same program so that's
what we're doing here we're importing
some libraries like numpy and pandas and
then we read the data file and if we
plot the data we see here it is the data
for for the years 1962 to 75 and we can
see that there is a certain Trend right
so this is a typical time series data
would look again some of you if you are
not familiar with time series and time
series analysis and so on I would
recommend you to go through some videos
around that which will make it easy to
understand this so this is our typical
time series data would look in this case
it is nothing but there is only one
variable which is milk production and it
is spread across several years so this
is going from 1962 to 75 and that value
has been plotted so if you see there is
a certain kind of a trend here which is
basically going upwards and there will
be some seasonality so time series data
has these three components right so it
will have a trend it will have a
seasonality it will have seasonality and
then it will have some Randomness so
that's what this graph is showing and
now if we want to perform analysis on
this time series analysis on this first
thing we need to do is split the data
into train and test and in this case we
will just use a straightforward method
which is taking the data for the first
13 years so the idea here is we need to
train our model right this is time
series data so what and we want to
predict for the future so the way we
need to use this is we have to take the
data for a certain period of time and
train our model and then we use a part
of the known data so that we can then
ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data I will show
you in the notebook as well Jupiter
notebook as well this has 13 years of
data so what we are doing is we are
taking the first 12 years and using that
as our training set right so 12 years
we're doing and this has about I think
14 years of data so we are taking 13
years of data for training purpose and
then we are using the last one year
remaining one year of data for testing
purpose because here what we can do is
this one year data we know the values
right because if we want to compare the
accuracy or anything like that we need
to know the value so in this case we
know the values of this one particular
year so we will use that but at the same
time we train the model for 13 years of
data and for the 14th Year we will ask
our model to predict and then compare it
with this known value so that we know
how accurate our model is I hope that
makes sense okay so that's what we are
doing here 156 is nothing but 12 into
13. on a monthly basis as we get the
data the next step is to scale the data
this is all regular data manipulation
data munching activity and then you
split it you are basically assigning the
train and test data to the to the scaled
variables and then you need to read the
data in batches so it is very important
as I mentioned earlier also that instead
of reading the entire data in one shot
you feed the data in batches so in order
to do that we are writing a function for
that that's all we are doing here so
that is still here what we have done is
regular Python Programming there is no
tensorflow as of now here okay so so far
what we have done is preparation data
preparation data munching now what we
are doing is actually training our model
so this is where tensorflow now comes
into picture so we are importing first
step is to import the tensorflow library
so this is how you do it import
tensorflow SDF and then you can Define
some variables or constants whichever
way now here of course there are a
couple of ways of doing it you can
create them as tensorflow nodes but that
is a little bit of an overhead we will
just use the regular python variables
are constant so here I am creating
regular python variables and I am saying
number of inputs is one so instead of
hard coding I'm just storing them as
variables so this is number of inputs is
one number of time steps is 12 number of
neurons is unread and so on right and
then learning rate is 0.03 and number of
iterations we are saying is four
thousand then we create placeholders now
we will be storing the independent
variables in X and the dependent
variables in y and this we will read
from an external file remember I told
you placeholders are used for getting
data from outside and then feeding it to
our model so that's the reason we have
two placeholders one for reading the X
values and another for reading the Y
values in this step we are only just
creating the nodes right so this is just
creating the graph and similarly we are
mentioning what is the loss function and
what is Optimizer and how to run the
optimizer and once that is done you are
initializing the variables and then
you're creating a saver variable or a
saver instance so saver is basically
nothing but in machine learning you can
train your model and you can save it for
later use so that's where the saving
comes into play we will see how to use
that as well and then the last step is
to create your session and run this
graph right so we are initializing the
variables remember this we run in it so
which is nothing but this one so we are
initializing the variables whatever are
there instead of hard coding remember in
earlier case we were hard coding how
many iterations so here we are saying
for the given number of iterations which
are stored in this maybe how many
iterations We Said is What is the value
of iterations this is training
iterations is four thousand so we
specify that based on the number of
training iterations next batch will
basically fetch the data and then we run
the session we are basically saying
train is the node which we will run in
the session and this will basically
train our model and this is more for
printing every 100 times you print it
that's all this there's nothing more it
so for example the output would look
somewhat like this this is for zero this
for 100 next for 200 and so on okay and
then you save the model you remember
saver we created so you save the model
for later use so this is our test data
remember we are doing this on training
data right so once the training data
training is done we then try to create
the inference on the test data so that
we can compare how accurate this is
right so this is how the test set would
look and then we will basically restore
this model okay because in the previous
slide we created the model and we stored
it so now we have to restore the model
and then run our test data against it
and see what are the values that are
predicted what are the Y values and then
compare with X to see the accuracy so
train seed is what we are seeing here so
that is what will have the the predicted
values and these predicted values what
we want to do is we want to create an
additional column because remember we
need to compare because we want to find
out the accuracy of this model so we
need to compare the predicted values
with the actual value so what we are
doing here is adding another column
called generator and assign a value to
that all right so this is the result of
the prediction and then if we need to
reshape because we have to show this in
the form of a monthly results so that's
what we are doing here and once we
generate the results and then display it
we can actually see it month wise here
and the actual and the generated values
okay so we create a data frame which is
a combination of the actual values and
the predicted values from the test set
and then we can plot to see how the
trend is as you can see pretty much the
actual value is in blue color and
generated or predicted value the curve
is in yellow color the trend is
maintained so it will probably it's not
a hundred percent accurate but the trend
is maintained all right so let's do one
thing let's go into the jupyter notebook
and take a look at how this works in
tensorflow environment actually the code
I will walk you through the code this is
my Jupiter notebook and the data is
taken from this particular Link in case
you're interested you can download it
from there and this is the data for the
years 1962 to 75. the first thing we do
is import these libraries because before
we start with the actual tensorflow
activity we need to prepare the data and
so on so for that you can use your
regular python libraries which are like
numpy pandas and so on so that's what we
are doing here and then we read the data
using pandas into a data frame so this
is a data frame milk is a data frame and
we will do some quick exploratory
analysis just to see how our data is
looking initials five records that we'll
get one two three four five that is the
head so it goes from 1960 to January to
1962 May once we re-change or basically
we need to split this into to month
specifically separately so that's what
we are doing here day to time so we kind
of do a little bit of a re-indexing and
then if we plot this this is how the
data look as you can see there is a
clear upward Trend and there is some
seasonality and so on but anyway we will
not break that up into those components
we will just use RNN to predict and test
okay so the next thing is to check some
if we can do run like info it will tell
us what is the information about this
data set so let us just run that okay so
it is just telling us how many total
columns and what is the size of the file
and so on and so forth again in case
you're interested in doing some
exploratory analysis so what we'll do
next is we will take the 13 years of
data for our training data set so what
are we going to do now let me step back
so what have we seen here we have seen
that there are 168 records so which is
nothing but 14 years of data we now have
to split this into our training and test
data set so how do we do that I think in
case of Time series we cannot do it like
80 20 like we do in normal letting in
normal machine learning process here it
is time series data so what we are going
to do is we will take out of this 14
years we will take the first 13 years of
data and we will use that for training
and then we will test it with the last
which is the 14th year data we will use
it for testing okay so that's what we
are going to do here so let's split that
so training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data I am taking
for training and then my test set will
consist of the bottom 12 observations
which is last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we'll use our scaling
rather we will use min max scalar and we
will just scale the data and now we do
it for both tests as well as train now
we are ready to create our RNN model but
before that one quick thing in order to
fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called Next
batch and how you want to fetch the
steps they are all defined as our
constants if you remember and that's
what this function is all about so we
Define that function we will be calling
that in our Training Method All right so
from here onwards up to there we are
done with the preparation of the data
and whatever functions or whatever are
required from here onwards is where the
tensorflow part starts so the first
thing we do is import the tensorflow
library typically this is a very
standard way of importing the library we
say import tensorflow as TF now TF is
nothing but a name so you can change it
to tf1 or ABC or XYZ whatever so this
part you can change but by and large
everybody uses this so we I would rather
recommend you also use the same syntax
so you say import tensorflow SDF so it's
very easy for others to understand as
well and then you declare Define a bunch
of constants that's what we are doing
here like for example the number of time
steps in this case it is 12 number of
neurons there are 100 number of outputs
it is only one and so on right and then
the learning rate and all that we are
declaring or defining those variables in
this particular block next is to create
placeholders you remember the
placeholders are used for feeding the
data so we have X and Y X is for the
input which is the independent variable
and Y is the output which is the
dependent variable and in our case these
are not different characteristics or
features but it is the same one feature
or one variable but it is over a period
of time so that's the only difference so
that's what we are doing here and now we
need to create our Network right the
neural network so in our case we said we
will create a RNN layer now there are
different ways or different formats of
RNN which is probably not in scope of
this module so for now we will just
assume assume we are creating one RNN
layer and one type of RNN is Gru cell so
we will use Gru cell and we use this
apis for creating our layer so each cell
will be with an output projection
wrapper there is a need for doing that
and again the details of this we will
probably do in another video where we
talk in detail about RNN so for now we
are creating a GRU cell with the wrapper
and the syntax for creating the gru cell
is like this the number of units which
we we said there should be 100 neurons
what will be the activation function in
this case it is relu and then number of
outputs in our case it is only one okay
so we create the cell here okay then we
got the gru cell and then we say what is
our output which is nothing but we get
the outputs and the states and their
states and which is uh the way we get
that is TF Dot N N dot Dynamic
underscore RNN so if you call this and
we pass the cell and the data which is
basically in placeholder again remember
all we are doing here is we are creating
just the nodes for the graph so nothing
is actually getting executed from a
tensorflow perspective okay all right so
once that is done now we need to pass
this calculate the outputs and the
states using the dynamic underscore
ordinal method and we pass the cell as a
parameter and then the X values as a
parameter and if we run that we will
have the outputs and the states and this
is where we actually run the Training
Method so or create not really run the
Training Method but we create the nodes
for the training and the optimizer then
we have the initialization of the
variables and we save this model we
create a saver object just to save the
model because we will then restore it
and run it to do our predictions so this
is what we will do here so there is
another node and this is where we
actually create a session and run the
training okay so let's go ahead and do
that that will take a little while
because we said 4000 iterations so we
will allow it to finish we will probably
come back once the training is completed
all right so the training is done now
let's go and run this on the test data
so let's just quickly take a look at the
test data set so this is our one year
data for the year of 1975 so if we see
this is from January February and so on
and we will pass this to our model so
what are we doing here we are restoring
the model here for example right this is
the path that we have given when we were
saving the model let's go back once and
show you let me show you where we did
the saving of the model yes so we save
the model here so that again we will
restore that and we will use that to run
it on our test data and see how well it
predicts so let's go ahead and run this
and this is just 12 record so this will
not take time remember I told you
training is what takes a lot of time the
regular inference this is called
inference doesn't take much time right
so it just depends on how much data
there were only 12 records here so it
was very quick but in training what we
do we pass this multiple times there are
iterations four thousand iterations
needed for example so that takes longer
and in general in machine learning deep
learning training is what takes the
maximum amount of time all right so
let's go ahead and see the results we
will in order to plot it we will have to
kind of adjust the format of the results
otherwise we will not be able to see it
in a proper way and then we will so this
is our so what we have done is we
created a data frame which consists of
the predicted value and the and the
actual value so this is the data frame
so this is the actual value this is 834
782 and so on this is what our model has
predicted so it may not be so easy to
see in a tabular format so let's go
ahead and plot it so that we can compare
these two so when we plot it you will
see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual Trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and training
this tutorial is about object detection
we will walk you through a tensorflow
code using which we will do object
detection in images we will tell you
what are the libraries that are required
a little bit about the Coco data set and
then we will show you the implementation
code itself a demo of the chord alright
so let's get started so what is the
tensorflow object detection API this is
an open source framework which is
actually provided by the tensorflow team
and there are train models available and
the sample code is also available which
we can use in order to easily detect
objects in images and videos this is
pretty robust and can detect objects
fairly quickly and this is very easy for
people to use as well people with very
less or no knowledge of machine learning
or deep learning can also with a little
bit of Python Programming knowledge can
actually use this API this library to
build object detection applications this
is a list of libraries that are required
and they have been shown in the code as
well the exact purpose of each of this
Library why it is required is out of the
scope of this tutorial but we will see
in the code as we walk through some of
these libraries how and why they are
used the Coco data set Coco stands for
common objects in context so this data
set consists of 300 000 images of 90
most commonly found objects like chairs
and tables and so on and so forth so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a large part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as I said the exact
details of each and every Library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe at later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and we also need this line of code to
make sure that once we run this object
detection the labeled images are
displayed within this notebook and many
of you by now must be familiar with this
and we will import a few utility
libraries and you will see that we will
be using some of these for visualization
purpose so once the objects are detected
we need to display the information what
that object is and then what percentage
of confidence the model has so all these
details that's the utility functions
that stored here and then the next part
is to prepare the model as I mentioned
we will be using an existing trained
model the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is SSD with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this URL let me
just quickly take you through this URL
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them where the
accuracy is much higher but they take
longer and there are some where the
accuracy is not so high and they are
much faster so they are faster but
accuracy than on B that very high so you
can play around with some of these and
we in this particular exercise or in
this particular tutorial we are using
this SSD model which is SSD mobile at
version one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in The Next Step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as
Frozen models so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called Frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if I can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it completes I have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
AI so that's good but this part is over
now let us see this part and yes both
are done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping basically what
this will do is your model as you may be
aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output the text it will
give some numbers so if there are five
classes it will say okay this belongs to
mod class 1 or 2 or 3 or 5 and so on the
numbers now each of these will obviously
the numbers will not make any sense to
the outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one may be a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a nump by array so
that the number array is what gets
system used by the model to do the
detection part of it so that is what
this method is all about so we will be
later on we will be calling that
function and next is preparation for
detection so here we are basically
telling where the images are stored and
how many images or what is the naming
convention or format of the images now
if you want you can modify this code for
example currently I have test underscore
images as my folder so let me go and
show this to you so this is under my
object detection folder I have another
subfolder where I am storing my images
which is text underscore images now you
can rename this folder and give some
other name and then in your code you can
probably give that particular name for
the subfold similarly the format of
these files what is the name and format
of this files here it is in a very
simple format which is the names of the
files are like each one beats 2 B3 and
so on so I have taken Beach as the theme
so I have images which are related to
beaches so this is beach one beach two
and then Beach three a few others but we
will use these three for our demo and so
that's what I'm saying here the name of
the images will be Beach something dot
jpeg which is uh jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either one two or three
based on in this particular for Loop
okay so that is what this is doing all
right so the next step is to run
inference on these images in a loop and
what we are basically doing here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is the function here and so
let me just run that piece of code and
here is basically where we are calling
this function so we are loading this
images and then we are calling this
function for each image and then we are
displaying this using the matplotlab
library so let's run this it will take
one image at a time and then detect the
images now the beauty is that the same
format of the code can be used for doing
object detection in a video so we have
another video for doing object detection
in a video so most of the code out there
will be reused from here and the only
thing is that instead of reading the
images from the local storage we read
the frames from the video and there is a
neat little video reader that is
available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just look out for that and
actually the information about that is
provided in the cards the I symbol so
that's the the video object detection in
video that's the separate tutorial all
right so now that we have all the pieces
together this the large cell is where
the whole action takes place so let's
run this and see how it looks so it will
take probably a little while and there
are about three images let's see what it
detects there we go so good so the first
one it has detected a person and that
two with 97 accuracy which is I think
good okay and then the next image it
detects
umbrella and chair there are a few other
options but it's not able to detect but
it has detected umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and the
chair with the 58 percent again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is uh probably not that bad
it sees there's something in the sky and
therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all I wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images in this video I will
walk you through the tensorflow code to
perform object detection in a video so
let's get started this part is basically
you're importing all the libraries we
need a lot of these libraries for
example numpy we need image i o date
time and fill and so on and so forth and
of course matplotlib so we import all
these libraries and then there are a
bunch of variables which have have some
parts for the files and folders so this
is regular stuff let's keep moving then
we import the matplotlib and make it the
Thin Line and a few more Imports all
right and then these are some warnings
we can just ignore them so if I run this
code once again it will go away all
right and then here onwards we do the
model preparation now what we're going
to do is we are going to use an existing
neural network model so we are not going
to chain a new one because that really
will take a long time and it needs a lot
of computation resources and so on and
it is really not required there are
already models that have been trained
and in this case it is the SSD with
mobile net as model that we are going to
use and this model is trained to detect
objects and it is readily available as
open source so we can actually use this
and if you want to use other models
there are a few more models available so
you can click on this link here and let
me just take you there there are a few
more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as a
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code right so these two
cells we have downloaded and import the
model and then once it is available
locally we will then load this into our
program all right so we are loading this
into memory and the you need to perform
a couple of additional steps which is
basically we need to to map the numbers
to text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into lump
IRS this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and we go down I'll skip
this section so this is the cell where
we are actually loading the video and
converting it into frames and then using
frame by frame we are detecting the
objects in the image so in this code
what we are doing basically is there are
a few lines of code what they do is
basically once they find an object a box
will be drawn around those each of those
objects and the input file the name of
the input video file is traffic it is
the extension is MP4 and we have this
video reader it's a excellent object
which is basically part of this class
called image i o so we can read and
write videos using that and the video
that we are going to use is traffic dot
MP4 you can use any mp4 file but in our
case I picked up video which has like a
car so let me just show you so this is
in this object detection folder I have
this mp4 file I'll just quickly create
this video it's a little slow yeah okay
so here we go this is the video it's a
short one relatively small video so that
for this particular demo and what it
will do is once we run our code it will
detect each of these cars and it will
annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's check with this
traffic video so let me go back so we
will be reading this frame by frame and
you know actually we will be reading a
video file but then we will be analyzing
it frame by frame and we will be reading
them at 10 frames per second that is the
rate we are mentioning here and
analyzing it and then annotating and
then writing it back so you will see
that we will have a video file named
something like this traffic underscore
annotated and we will see the annotated
video so let's go back and run through
this piece of code and then we will come
back and see the annotated video this
might take a little while so I will
pause the video after running this
particular cell and then come back to
show you the results all right so let's
go ahead and run it so it is running now
and it is also important that at the end
you close the video writer so that it is
similar to file pointer when you open a
file you should also make sure you close
it so that it doesn't hog the resources
so it's very similar at the end of it
the last piece or last line of code
should be video underscore writer Dot
close all right so I'll pause and then
I'll come back okay so I will see you in
a little bit all right so now as you can
see here the processing is done The
Hourglass has disappeared that means the
video has been processed so let's go
back and check the annotated video we'll
go back to my file manager so this was
the original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated MP4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here it has got each of these
cars getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so I think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play some more and see if
it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us here so
this is a car and it has confidence
level of 69 percent okay this is again a
car all right so basically till the end
it goes and detects each and every car
that is passing by now we can quickly
repeat this process for another video
let me just show you the other video
which is a cat again there is uh this
cat is not really moving or anything but
it is just standing there staring and
moving a little slowly and our
application will our network will detect
that this is a cat and even when the cat
moves a little bit in the other
direction it'll continue to detect and
show that it is a cat Okay so yeah so
this is our original video is let's go
ahead and change our code to analyze
this one and see if it detects our
Network detects this cat close this here
we go and go back to my code all we need
to do is change this traffic to cat the
extension it will automatically pick up
because it is given here and then it
will run through so very quickly once
again what it is doing is this video
reader video underscore reader has a
neat little feature or interface whereby
you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you are in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works I is very easy to handle this
all right so now let's once again run
just this cell rest of the stuff Remains
the Same so I will run this cell again
it will take a little while so the r
classes come back I will pause and then
come back in a little while all right so
the processing is done let's go and
check the annotated video go here so we
have get
annotated.mp4 let's play this all right
so you can see here it is detecting the
cat and in the beginning you also saw it
detected something else here there it
looks like I detected one more object so
let's just go back and see what it has
detected here let's see yes so what is
it trying to show here it's too small
not able to see but it is trying to
detect something I think it is saying it
is a car I don't know all right okay so
in this video there's only pretty much
only one object which is the cat and uh
let's wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just in a
little bit that's going to happen and we
will see there we go and in spite of
turning the other way I think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it I think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it in this tutorial we will take the use
case of recognizing handwritten digits
this is like a hello world of deep
learning and this is a nice little MNS
database is a nice little database that
has images of handwritten digits nicely
formatted because very often in deep
learning and neural networks we end up
spending a lot of time in preparing the
data for training and with MNS database
we can avoid that you already have the
data in the right format which can be
directly used for training and mnist
also offers a bunch of built-in utility
functions that we can straight away use
and call those functions without
worrying about writing our own functions
and that's one of the reasons why MNS
database is very popular for training
purposes initially when people want to
learn about deep learning and tensorflow
this is the database that is used and it
has a collection of 70 000 handwritten
digits and a large part of them are for
training then you have tests just like
in any machine learning process and then
you have validation and all of them are
labeled so you have the images and their
label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are
handwritten images collected from a lot
of individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is MNS
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our tensorflow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with the label
information and the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for Simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two-dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it's a
28 by 28 so there are 7484 pixels so
pixel number one starts here it goes all
the way up to 28 then 29 starts here and
goes up to 56 and so on and the pixel
number 784 is here so we take all these
pixels flatten them out and feed them
like one single line into our neural
network and this is a what is known as a
soft Max layer what it does is once it
is trained it will be able to identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10 neurons each
signifying a digit and at any given
point of time when you feed an image
only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated so for example if this is
strained properly and if you feed a
number nine like this then this
particular neuron gets activated so you
get an output from this neuron let me
just use a pen or a laser to show you
here okay so you're feeding a number
nine let's say this has been trained and
now if you're feeding a number nine this
will get activated now let's say you
feed one to the trained Network then
this neuron will get activated if you
feed two this neuron will get activated
and so on I hope you get the idea so
this is one type of a neural network or
an activation function known as soft Max
layer so that's what we will be using
here this is one of the simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and we
will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through briefly here and
then we will go into the Jupiter
notebook where the actual code is and we
will run that as well so as a first step
first of all we are using python here
and that's why the syntax of the
language is Python and the first step is
to import the tensorflow library so and
we do this by using this line of code
saying import tensorflow as TF TF is
just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this TF is
tensorflow is available as an object in
the name of TF and then you can run its
methods and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and mnis database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just use pen to show what exactly
it is so when you do this one hot true
what happens is each label is stored in
the form of an array of 10 digits and
let's say the number is 8 okay so in
this case all the remaining values there
will be a bunch of zeros so this is like
array at position zero this is at
position one position two and so on and
so forth let's say this is position
seven then this is position eight that
will be 1 because our input is 8 and
again position 9 will be zero okay so
one hot encoding this one hot encoding
true will kind of load the data and such
a way that the labels are in such a way
that only one of the digits has a value
of one and that indicates So based on
which digit is one we know what is the
label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a 2 here let's say then the
labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as 0 the 0th position the
first position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can check how the data
is looking by displaying the the data
and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not release see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and this tells you how many
images are there in each set so they're
training there are 55 000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10 000 and then validation there are
5000. so all together there are 70 000
images all right so let's move on and we
can view the actual image by using the
matplot flip library and this is how you
can view this is the code for viewing
the images and you can view them in
color or you can view them in grayscale
so the cmap is what tells in what way we
want to view it and what are the maximum
values and the minimum values of the
pixel value so these are the Max and
minimum values so of the pixel values so
maximum is one because this is a scaled
value so 1 means it is white and 0 means
it is black and in between is it can be
anywhere in between black and white and
the way to train the model that is a
certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and the first step is to
create some placeholders and then you
create a model in this case we will use
the softmax model one of the simplest
ones and placeholders are primarily to
get the data from outside into the
neural network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your remember these are your weights and
biases so for in our case there are 10
neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron 1
it has it receives all the 784 this is
the second neuron this also receives all
the 700 so each of these inputs needs to
be multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a matrix of
784 values for each of the neurons and
so it is like a 10 by 784 Matrix because
there are 10 neurons and similarly there
are biases now remember I mentioned
biases only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything has variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as I mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of for
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication TF you
remember this TF was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so TF is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or maximal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with W
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding B and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw Sigma x i w i so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to Define what is our loss function and
what is our Optimizer so in this case is
we again use the tensorflows apis so TF
dot NN softmax cross entropy with logits
is the API that we will use and reduce
mean is what is like the mechanism
whereby which says that you reduce the
error and Optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what Optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
Optimizer we discussed about this in
couple of slides earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that Optimizer and that
will kick start the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we wanted
to run so for example in this case we
are saying Thousand Steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques shown here
so let us get into the code quickly and
see how it works so this is our Cloud
environment now you can install
tensorflow on your local machine as well
I'm showing this demo on our existing
Cloud but you can also install
tensorflow on your local machine and
there is a separate video on how to set
up your tensorflow environment you can
watch that if you want to install your
local environment or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
Google Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of
these you can use and run and try the
code okay so it has got started
with a login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
Code walkthrough uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that the
one hot is encoding is set to True one
hot encoding right as I explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately and if we
just check what is the type of the data
so you can see that this is a data sets
python data sets and if we
check the number of images the way it
looks so this is how it looks it is an
array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
cleaning images there are 55 000 and
there are test images 10 000 and then
validation images 5000. now let's take a
quick look at the data itself
visualization so we will use
um matplotlib for this
and if we take a look at the shape now
shape gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or or the arrays if you will so
in this case the training data set if we
see the size of the training data set
using the method shape it says there are
55 000 and 50 000 by 784 so remember the
784 is nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into
28 so that is equal to 784 so that's
what it is showing now we can take just
one image and just see what is the the
first image and see what is the shape so
again size obviously it is only 784.
similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how it it shows a
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is blank so that's why you
will mostly see Zero say that it is
black or white but then there are these
values are so the values are actually
they are scaled so their values are
between 0 and 1. okay so this is what
you're seeing so certain locations there
are some values and then other locations
there are zeros
so that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image if you
want to view it this is how you view it
so you create like do this reshape and
matplotlab has this feature to show you
these images so we will actually use the
function called I am show and then if
you pass this parameters appropriately
you will be able to see the different
images now I can change the values in
this position so which image we are
looking at right so we can say
if I want to see what is there in maybe
right so
5000 has three similarly you can just
say five what is in five
five as eight what is in fifty
[Music]
again eight so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how I'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with Jupiter notebooks shift
enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you want to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all
so that is how
this score gets executed and here again
we can check what is the maximum value
and what is the minimum value of this
pixel values as I mentioned this is it
is scaled so therefore it is between the
value slide between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
chill values okay so one for this 10 is
for each neuron there are 10 neurons and
784 is for the pixel values inputs that
are given which is 28 into 28 and the
biases as I mentioned one for each
neuron so there will be 10 biases they
are stored in a variable by the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
placeholder and this will have values in
the form of 10 digit 10 digit arrays and
since we set one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the label for that particular
number all right then we have cross
entropy which is nothing but the loss
loss function and we have the optimizer
we have chosen gradient descent as our
Optimizer that the training process
itself so the training process is
nothing but to minimize the cross
entropy which is again nothing but the
loss function so we Define all of this
in the form of a graph so the up to here
remember what we have done is we have
not exactly executed any tensorflow code
till now we are just preparing the graph
the execution plan that's how the
tensorflow code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow because the way
tensorflow programming is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this but even in spark the
the programming the code it's self is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the execution happens slightly
differently but in tensorflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed in the same way as you have
written so that that's something you
need to understand and a little bit of
practices needed for this so so far what
we have done up to here is creating the
variables and feeding the variables and
or rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and the graph that's all
defining maybe the what kind of a
network you want to use for example we
want to use a soft Max and so on so you
have created the variables how to load
the data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution in
tensorflow so the first step for doing
any execution in 10 the flow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code in tensorflow and in
order to execute the code what you will
need is a session tensorflow session so
TF dot session will give you a session
and there are a couple of different ways
in which you can do this but one of the
most common methods of doing this is
with what is known as a with Loop so you
have a width TF dot session as says and
with a colon here and this is like a
block starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and this session is valid till this
block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this with block this
is known as a width block so with TF dot
session as says you say SAS dot run in
it now says Dot one will execute a node
that is specified here so for example
here we are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying TF dot
session so an instance of the session
gets created and we are calling that SAS
and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init so we say run that particular node
and that is when the initialization of
the variables happens now what this does
is if you have any variables in your
code in our case we have W is a variable
and B is a variable so any variables
that we created you have to run this
code you have to run the initialization
of these variables otherwise you will
get an error okay so that is the that's
what this is doing then
we within this with block we specify a
for Loop and we are saying we want the
system to iterate for thousand steps and
perform the training
that's what this for Loop does run
training for 1000 iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching the data or these images
remember there are about 50 000 images
but it cannot get all the images in one
shot because it will take up a lot of
memory and performance issues will be
there so this is a very common way of
Performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe 500 depending on
the size of your system and so on and so
forth so in this case we are saying okay
get me 100 images at a time and get me
only the training images remember we use
only the training data for training
purpose and then we use test data for
test purpose you must be familiar with
machine learning so you must be aware of
this but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and You observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
MNS database because they have provided
some very nice helper functions which
are readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using MNS database and that's why we
use this for the initial learning phase
okay so when we say fetch what it will
do is it will fetch the images into X
and the labels into Y and then you use
this batch of 100 images and you run the
cleaning so SAS dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the new
Network and thereby all the W's and B's
get updated to till it reaches thousand
iterations in this case the exit
criteria is thousand but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
1000 iterations and typically by the end
of this thousand iterations the model
would have learned to recognize these
handwritten images obviously it will not
be 100 accurate okay so once that is
done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensorflow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you are trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not TF dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is calculated as well so this
is the accuracy and that is what we are
trying to see how accurate the model is
in predicting these numbers or these
digits okay so let us run this this
entire thing is in one cell so we will
have to just run it in one shot it may
take a little while let us see and uh
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
percent okay now which is pretty good
for such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90 percent accuracy
however in real life this is probably
not sufficient so there are other ways
in to increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and so that this
accuracy can be increased Beyond 90 with
that we have reached the end of day six
of our data science week on day 7 when
we are going to learn about data science
interview questions thank you all for
watching today's live session see you
tomorrow thanks again and keep learning